Hi everybody, what is up?
My conscious collective, it is I once again,
Rich Roll here after a brief respite,
the nature of which we will soon elucidate,
breaking organic gluten-free bread with my main squeeze
Mr. Adam Skolnick, master of Penn,
scroll and word here to deposit sound waves derived
from ones and zeros into your ear candle, ear canal,
into your ear canal.
For those who are new typically we break down matters,
ranging from banal to consequential.
We do a wee bit of show and tell,
we share a few wins of the week
and we rounded all out by answering
some of the questions dropped on our voicemail,
which you can ring up at 4 2 4 2 3 5 4 6 2 6.
Today, we're gonna do things a little bit differently
We're going to hone in and focus on one story.
That story being that of the Iron Cowboy
and his mind bending 100 not just 100,
101 consecutive iron distance,
Iron Cowboy distance as he likes to say triathlons,
which is a feat or a feat of how do I describe this?
A feat of fitness prowess
to which both of us, you and I, Adam bore witness
we are gonna share a few wins.
And then we're gonna go to my interview
with Minneapolis Mayor Jacob Frey,
which was recorded during the final week
of the George Floyd trials.
So we're not gonna do listen to questions this week,
but before we dive in a quick word from the sponsors
that make this fiasco possible.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome
but I wanna snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches, seven days a week,
and many other features to learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com
and right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff,
people for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code,
RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
And we're back Adam,
we have two things to celebrate today.
The first of which is the fact that yesterday
was your first, your very first father's day as a father.
It was.
How are you doing?
I cannot deny it was a rite of passage,
but I'm not festive Rich,
I'm not a fan, I'm not that guy,
I'm not here to be festive because a day,
a certain day comes up and they tell you it's that day.
I also resist the social contract
that mandates we celebrate holidays
and other people on appointed dates on the calendar.
Exactly, I don't need my wife
to paint an Instagram soliloquy of my greatness
on a certain day, like these other...
As long as she's giving mothers
on her randomly appointed days.
Yeah, no, I expect it several times a week.
Just not on father's day.
It's sort of like the bridge and tunnel crowd,
its like amateur night.
But that was a different era
that was the exclusive exclusiveness era.
Exclusivity is the inclusion era now.
We're both having trouble
with our vocabulary and speaking.
But no, but it was, it was a rite of passage.
It was the first one I fed my child
I bought paint for his new bedroom.
I swim ran, but mostly I fixated
on a 66 year old German scientist named Juliane Diller.
Tell me about her.
She is the "woman" who fell to earth.
Did you know about this story?
Well, I didn't until it popped up in my Twitter feed
and was set a blaze,
it was trending on Twitter the other day.
There's crazy story.
Incredible like there was a New York times story
about this, not the first time her story
has been told the headline was something like,
this woman fell nearly two miles to the earth
or something and survived.
I like how the New York times kind of uses
Art of ClickBait titles now
to draw attention to the stories like these.
Well, cause this is really an environmental science story,
but it does have this life and death element.
I mean, she's the sole survivor
of the deadliest lightning strike disaster
in aviation history, it's coming up on 50 years
this Christmas, when she was 17 years old,
she was flying to the Panguana Research Station
in the Amazon basin of Peru,
the oldest Amazonian research station in Peru.
And so she lived there her parents were these zoologists
that set up this station from Germany
and she lived there, they lived in Lima for a while
and then when she was 14,
she got moved to the middle of the jungle
and she was on the flight back with her mother
and all of a sudden 20 minutes into this 50 minute flight,
everything starts shaking the luggage,
the overhead compartments open up.
it's like the bad movie like where everything's showering.
The people, this has really happened.
And she looks out the window
and the wing gets hit by lightning,
she sees it and then her mother turns to her and says,
it's all over now, like in a really steady,
like how German is that to be that cool under like,
just total zoologist it's all over now, honey.
But what happens is she's in this bench of three seats
in near the back of the plane
and the plane breaks apart.
And all of a sudden, she's next thing,
she's flying through the air, no plane.
She says like the plane left me
I didn't leave the plane.
And she starts, she's just doing circles,
like a spinning leaf towards the jungle canopy.
And it looks like she described it
as looking like broccoli tops.
And she passes out and she wakes up under that seat
with a broken collarbone and a bad cut
and a torn skirt, but nothing else.
And she's got bad swollen eye
and then she's has to hike through the jungle
for 11 days with just candy.
And she finds water, follows the water,
and eventually finds a logging camp 11 days later...
Its the craziest story,
I just pulled it up on the screen here.
86 people on this flight, she's 17,
she's sitting next to her mom.
And there's that amazing quote about
how she didn't feel like she got objected from the plane.
The plane just sort of left her and everything was quiet
and she's buckled into this seat,
a three seat kind of sectional and blacks out
and wakes up essentially pretty much
fine broken collar bone.
But the big thing was that she lost her glasses,
she's terribly near-sighted.
And then has to figure out
how to in the middle of the Amazon,
figure out how to find civilization crazy.
It takes 11 days and she's 17 so 86 people,
everybody dies except her it's unbelievable.
And she...
How do you fall two miles?
Two miles.
I don't care how...
There must be something about the blacking out part
that has to go limp and you don't have that,
you're not rigid I mean...
And she must've been the,
I would think that the canopy caught her
and so slowed the fall
and then hit like kind of a dense leaflet,
like leaf litter must be like,
the loam must be like so thick and soft earth.
That that must have helped I mean, she was,
she started to make her way.
I think she laid there for a day until
the search helicopters, the search planes.
She couldn't hear them anymore
she thought they weren't gonna come for her.
And then she looked or like, as she walked away,
she'd see some of her fellow passengers, like
dead in the ground.
And she was searching like, women's fit footwear
to see if it's her mother,
her mother never painted her toenails.
I mean, she was doing that.
And as she was walking,
she realized I haven't done anything with my life.
If I survive this, I'm gonna do some good.
This photo of her revisiting the crash site in 1998
with Werner Herzog.
Werner.
Which is so awesome.
It's awesome because you just talked about Werner.
(chuckles)
Did you hear that story?
That Van told about meeting Werner Herzog?
I haven't gotten to that part yet.
It's great.
It tells a great story, it's an unbelievable story.
This woman and then goes on
to be this legendary biologist committed
to this particular part of the world.
Yeah and it's become this preserve
with 500 species of trees,
160 types of reptiles and amphibians,
100 types of fish, seven varieties of monkey,
380 bird species, there's 100 of insect species,
there's more bat species in their preserve
than all of Europe.
I mean, it's incredible.
And the story goes on to basically say
that we are at 16, 17% of the Amazon has been eradicated.
And if you get to 20%, you get to a point of no return.
She's saying as a scientist and that,
but until that point, if we can preserve more of it,
we're in good shape.
but we already, she says the average temperature
has gone up four degrees
since when she was a kid.
Why is this article being written now.
The 50 I think the peg was a 50 years ago
this Christmas is the anniversary of this crash.
And it's this big aviation disaster.
I thought the crash was Christmas Eve.
Yeah, it's Christmas Eve.
I don't know why, it makes me wanna read her book.
Well, this is a good way to kick this off.
I started, we started with an interesting story
right out of the gate.
All I said was Adam, how you doing?
Well, it's our one year anniversary...
I know speaking of anniversaries,
we're celebrating this woman's surviving this crash.
It is also the one-year anniversary
of us sitting together and doing this thing.
I know.
How do you feel about that?
It's been a lot easier than those 11 days, I think.
(laughing)
But I feel great I mean, it's happy.
I'm happy to be here I think as we get into
the Iron Cowboy stuff, I think I've reached another level
of understanding of the power of the Rich Roll Podcast.
And I am pleased to be here.
It's been an amazing iteration and evolution of the show.
It's been an absolute joy to do this with you.
I've really enjoyed it,
the audience definitely loves it.
We're gonna talk a little bit about that in a minute.
When we talk about the Iron Cowboy,
the funny thing is despite all the kind of heavy stuff
that we cover and how intellectual we try to be
about all these stories,
the primary focus seems be on this relationship that we have
and the threat that Brogan Graham poses to that.
How are we working out this social dynamic?
I still get broken comments sometimes.
(laughing)
It's unbelievable.
I know, well, it's a powerful book
Brogan's a powerful man.
The human mind works.
But that's good how are you Rich enough about me.
Am okay, speaking of father's day,
I celebrated father's day with my wife, 6,000 miles away in,
and she's in Europe right now.
Mathis one of my daughters was in Santa Barbara.
Jaya wanted to know if I could go see a friend.
It was so you can't complain
about socially mandated holidays
and how you have a resistance to them.
If you're not gonna reap the results of being on
what it feels like to be on the receiving end of that
with like-minded individuals.
You lobby for that life.
No, it was nice
like the boys made dinner with Jaya
and we watched a movie last night, but it was pretty chill.
I did, I was supposed to be there.
All of this happened because originally
I was supposed to be in Sun Valley doing this
everlasting event the 29029 events.
So everybody made separate plans
because I wasn't even meant to be in town to begin with.
We didn't actually do the...
I was gonna do it I mean, I did it in Utah.
It must've been two years ago,
year and a half ago at this point,
I was really looking forward to it.
But there was with Julie being in Europe,
there was too much going on with the kids,
Mathis produced a pop-up event for 30 vendors in Hollywood,
all these high school kids
who designed garments and jewelry
and all kinds of cool stuff.
It was like a frat party for artistic Hollywood kids
at this warehouse.
But it was pretty cool, like she's an entrepreneur, man.
She put this whole thing together
with a friend and...
I wonder where she gets it from.
So I wanted to be able to attend that
and also Jaya just started a new school.
I couldn't not be here for that.
And there's some other things going on
so just it was the right decision to opt out of doing
what I like doing,
which is being outdoors and doing hard things,
but family first, my friends.
So yeah it was pretty uneventful.
Things are opening up here in California, pretty rapidly.
I'm anxious to get back in the pool
I haven't gone online and check to see
what the pools in my area are doing right now.
But I suspect if they're not already fully open,
they're going to be soon.
And I'm looking forward to that happening.
Well that would cause you've had some back issues
is that the swimming help with that?
It helps and it doesn't aggravate it,
it's such a gentle way of working out in terms
of your joints and you know, all of that so...
It was swimming pool warm in the ocean, this,
I mean, at the surface.
It was like temperature right now.
It was 68 degrees at Westward.
Like I was getting 68 on my watch after some dives,
it was about 63 at the bottom maybe like from 20 foot on,
it was probably like 63, 62.
68 at the surface.
So if you're just swimming, I mean, it's like,
it's gorgeous I was lucky enough April basically carved out
some beach time for us
and hooked up a nice brunch on Sunday,
shout out to the lovely wife.
Cool man, let's dive into the big story.
Focus on today, the recap of the Iron Cowboy Conquer 101.
So as many of you guys know by now,
especially if you follow this show
or you follow me on Instagram on June 8th, James Lawrence,
AKA the Iron Cowboy achieves something.
I personally honestly did not think possible
by completing a hundred consecutive iron distance triathlons
for people who are listening or watching,
who don't know what that is.
It's a 2.4 mile swim followed by 112 miles on the bike,
celebrated with a marathon 26.2 miles.
All in one day he did a hundred of these in a row,
walking out the front door of his house,
making a short jaunt down the street in his neighborhood
in Lindon, Utah to a local pool that he essentially rented.
It's like about Lindon.
It's like Calabasas set against the Rocky Mountains.
I don't know about that it's a little bit different.
It's a unique place,
but he kind of did this all in his general area.
It's a flat terrain as long as you don't go up
in the mountains and essentially went out his front door
and did this every single day, not missing
this is the important part did not miss a single day.
There was no days off,
No days off.
And then he celebrated this insane accomplishment
by waking up the next day,
after doing a hundred and doing it again.
So the conquer 100 is actually the conquer 101.
So I wanna talk about our reflections on all of this,
as well as our impressions of actually being present
and bearing witness to this.
You went a couple of times
we each were there.
It's been a while since we've done a roll on.
So I showed up on day 91
and just backtracking a little bit.
When James did his 50 iron distance triathlons
in 50 states in 50 days,
I showed up on the final day
and ran the final marathon with him.
It was such an amazing experience.
I did a podcast with him
before he set off on that experience.
I didn't want afterwards
I made a vlog about being there on that final day
and I wasn't gonna let this experience eclipse my attention.
I wasn't sure I was gonna be able to make it
on the final day.
Cause Jaya's birthday was the day after that
there was a bunch of stuff going on at home.
So I had this window of opportunity
to show up for day 91 I wanted to jump on
in the event that I would not make it
there for the final day.
So I was there on day 91, I walked,
it's kind of like a power walk
like he was walking these marathons
for a large chunk of them.
Walking doesn't really tell the tale
because he's moving pretty quickly
like you, it's easy to fall off the back.
You're just walking like you have to get a job to catch up.
If you do that, you'd have to jog to catch up.
Like he's really figured out how to move it,
pretty quickly while walking
and got to spend a little bit of time with him.
I mean, one of the cool things about doing a day
other than the final day is that there's less people,
you get some FaceTime I surprised them
I was able to have some cool conversations with him,
take his temperature on how he was feeling,
spend a little bit of time talking to his friends,
his wing men, some of the people
that have flown in from all over to get,
get a little piece of this for themselves,
which we're gonna talk about and,
spend some time with his kids, Lucy in particular.
And it was amazing I loved it.
And then I was able to figure it out
to go back there for the final day
and we were both present for that experience.
Yeah, man, that was incredible
I mean, I'm so glad that you were there for that.
I mean, for me, I got interested in this,
but I didn't even know until it had started
when you started to bring it up on roll-ons
I didn't know who James was.
I hadn't heard of his first record, the 50
and then got interested.
And so I went out there for the New York times sports
in that capacity, which was the first,
my first on the ground field assignments since COVID,
my first flight and my first and my first flight
was delayed three and a half hours,
so that was pretty fine.
It took you awhile to get there?
But then I checked into a nice little hotel
on the side of the 15 next to Guns and Ammo Superstore.
Yeah, there's no shortage of gun shops
and shooting ranges in this part of the world.
It was the glamour of the road hit me right away.
But it was, I got there just in time
to get to the finish of day 98.
I literally drove in 45 minutes
before they finished in the park.
And it's in Lindon is kinda like a new build town
that used to probably be kind of a hay farm area,
and where they ride is to the existing hay farms now.
And it's kind of between Provo and Salt Lake,
which is Salt Lake being a budding Tech Center now
it's like, it's coming,
it's on the come up and they're right in that corridor.
And there's a lot of cyclists,
a lot of athletes in that area because of altitude
and just, it's a nice place to live.
There's a lot of sunshine
and so that was cool I love Utah.
I mean, Utah is one of the most beautiful states we have
and I've always loved it.
So it was fun to go there.
Day 99 woke up at five to get to the swim.
And my plan was to swim with them, which I did do.
And so but I didn't expect the pool to be so packed
like when I had originally organized to go out there
and I was talking with Lucy,
I said, would I be able to swim?
She said, yes, any day, but the last day.
And I said, because the last day
is already fully booked out, I thought,
so they're keeping track of who's swimming.
When I got there the pool was like five two a lane
and so, but I got in anyway and I did most of,
the 2.4, but it was like a Forrest Gump experience.
Like he swims a hundred and he wants to swim on,
he starts the next a hundred on the two minutes.
He basically has 41 hundreds on the two minutes.
And he would stop and take a sip.
So whenever he stops though,
the entire pool goes dormant,
maybe a couple stragglers in the far lane,
its total Forrest camp.
Like he stops, they stop.
He goes, they go...
Hold on a second, please tell me you didn't wear
your snorkeling mask situation for this swim.
Rich Roll you know me better than that.
(chuckles)
What do you think I wore in that pool?
(laughing)
Did you not look around and notice that everybody else
was likely wearing typical swimming goggles.
There's only one.
There's a reason for that.
It's only one mass guy in every pool.
Yes, they're like, who's this guy from Los Angeles
from the New York times wearing a snorkeling mask?
It is camo, it is camo a,
what's it called the swim not speed
as with the longer trunks,
the little jammers, my camo jammers with my thing,
but it was the sun like there was still like a sliver moon
over the Rockies and sun hadn't come up yet.
It was quite beautiful and then afterwards,
like someone's making great vegan pancakes on the griddle.
He eats his breakfast and the shower
He is definitely not vegan.
No as we, as I learned over the course of the day.
You sent me a photo of him eating a pancake in the shower.
Yeah he was eating his blueberry pancakes
in the showers he got ready.
So then they took off on the bike
and I kind of followed them around a little bit,
just at the beginning.
And then at the end, then at the halfway point I met them.
They would all descend,
the cyclist would descend on this mini Mart
in the middle of pace in Utah.
And it was pretty fun to watch that.
And then I followed him around the Hay Fields for awhile
and then I did some time on the marathon
like you, I walked a chunk of it
that evening and that was my day 99.
And what was cool is, was the community
that kind of rallied around him
and the comradery and all these individuals that had
and on day 99 and day 100,
I really focused a lot on talking to some people that,
that had done some really amazing personal first,
like a neighbor that they have
he's not a really tall guy
so he was 60 pounds overweight when this thing started
and he started to show up,
he'd never done swam a lap in his life.
And he comes in and James and sissy gets in the pool
he gets in the pool,
starts to cobble together pieces of the swim piece
of the ride piece of the run.
He loses 35 pounds by day 98,
he finishes the entire full distance,
finishing it after everyone else.
And then he has still had six miles to walk.
Is he the Hispanic guy?
Yeah.
I talked to him, that's from credible story.
He's from his family's from Mexico,
but he has a Japanese name.
I'll get it for you to have it queued up here.
But, so that was one story.
His name was Takashi Inzunza and that's one story.
Another story, Hailey Ingram Jones
she gave birth to her first child in January.
Her husband was really into this
and he joined kind of the caravan,
did a couple of full distance triathlons,
several marathons he was one of the guys
in the yellow shirts that were kind of keeping a bubble.
He was one of those guys
she had never written a road bike before.
She'd never swim laps in her life,
but she just felt left out, felt bad.
She felt like it sounded to me she,
they were surprised by the pregnancy
and she wasn't like fully mentally prepared
for her whole life to change.
And I talked to her several times
and she was just feeling she was in that funk
and she just ended up like taking two weeks
to kind of feel it out,
did 133 mile ride on her dad's bike that she borrowed
worked out, looked at YouTube for a workable swim stroke.
And then she just said the heck with it,
two weeks later, she has the whole dumn thing full distance.
So crazy and this really is the story here.
It's about the power of community
and the example that James set
and the vibe of inclusivity
and this sense of heightened possibility
where these people, I mean,
that's a woman who would never even conceive
or consider doing a full distance Ironman
that person's not signing up
for an official iron man
but seeing those people out there every single day,
suddenly it seems like,
hey, maybe I can do this and you chip away at it.
And then a week later,
you're like doing the whole thing, it's crazy.
Two brothers, 18 and 14, their mother was a triathlete.
She died after a long bout with breast cancer
they heard about that was last August.
They heard about this after it had already started.
Maybe in may I forget
and the younger brother did several marathons.
The older brother did two full distance
and several marathons with his brother.
I mean, this is like, and it's the same thing.
Every time it's almost with minimal training
we met a PhD student from Mumbai
who lives in Dallas that moved there to do the marathon.
He is getting his PhD and like AI.
And he had promised himself that
he would one day run a marathon,
but just couldn't get himself off the couch
to get going on it and was following
what James was doing on Instagram
and just basically said,
screw it flew from Dallas to Utah,
got a hotel room and just started showing up.
We moved him with his buddy who lives in...
He sort of set up shop here though,
he relocate, essentially.
So he'd come and join in the marathon,
which he did a little bit here and there--
This is Said Saeed.
And then he started just doing the whole marathon.
I think he did six of them or seven of them
or something like that would do his schoolwork
during the day cause it's all virtual.
And then show up at, they'd start the marathon around,
between like 1:30 and 3:00 every day..
And bang it out.
And the mother is Hailey Ingram Jones
and the boys are the Lindbergs, Jacob and Sam.
The point is there's unlimited stories like this
like when I was there on day 91,
I met so many people
who had some version of that same story.
They'd lost a ton of weight or they changed their life
and they just wanted to come out support James
and also have this experience for themselves.
I mean, again and again and again.
Yeah I mean that the,
I think the unexpected galvanizing force
of this whole thing
was the fact that by doing a hundred in a row,
he made a full distance Iron Cowboy triathlon field doable.
Like personally,
someone who's done a sprint triathlon has done this,
the smaller swim runs and loves to get out there.
I it's been a long time since I've ridden bikes regularly,
but I used to do that a lot.
I never thought it was doable for me.
I never even considered that
it would be doable for me personally.
Its been presented and marketed
as the most difficult thing anybody
could ever commit endurance challenge.
And he normally it in such a way,
which is perhaps why the Ironman brand is not so crazy.
Maybe not, but in a way it's actually good for them.
It is ultimately
because more people are gonna say,
oh, I could do that I'm gonna sign up for one.
Well, that's the thing I was there.
I remember telling you, I'm like for the first time,
I feel like I could actually do this,
but it's weird because first of all,
let's keep it real James Lawrence is an elite athlete.
This is not, we're talking about...
His off the charts.
He's off at like when he was before
so he's also a crazy competitive and gets his mind like
when, before all this,
when he was just like a guy tending bar
and golfing in Canada,
he like heard about some contests on the Ferris wheel,
in his town.
And he had to stay on the Ferris wheel for 10 days
like from 8:00 AM to park close at 10:00 PM.
And the last guy standing was gonna win out for 25 grand
or something like that.
And he does that, like he wins.
Yeah, he demonstrates his metal Ford it's early, early.
That sets the stage, it's almost cinematic.
Like it's for shadows, these things to calm you.
He told that story the first time he came
on the podcast it's wild.
But that's a great story.
It is a great story and you know, that being said,
that's one of the many reasons
why I mentioned earlier on the podcast
and I said this to James on day 91 when I was with him,
I said, you're so physically strong.
Like he's not built like a runner or a triathlete
like he's a brick, this guy's ripped.
But that strength is eclipsed by his mental strength.
And my fear was that,
because this is a guy who's just never gonna quit
like he, there's no way this guy's gonna pull out.
Like he is not gonna fall prey
to some kind of mental defect
that's gonna, get them to pull the rip cord.
He will literally break his body before he says stop
and I explained, I said that to him.
I go, that's, what I said on the pockets,
that's my perspective on this.
So I worry about the longterm physical implications
of what you're doing.
And he proceeded to tell me some pretty crazy stories
about what he's endured and whether
that aren't really part of what's been shared on Instagram.
Basically, we all saw him after I don't know,
it must've been like five or eight of these things
when his ankles were all swollen up,
he was having unbelievable shin pain
could barely walk and it looked like
the whole thing was gonna crater or teeter.
And then he through a friend of a friend,
got hooked up with an orthopedic surgeon
who knew somebody who was working on
this sort of device that was a bit of a,
what do you call it?
Like a, a brace.
He said it was a carbon fiber insole
that with the brace secured it.
So it allowed it some sort of cushioning...
He customized it though,
there was clinical application for it.
And they customized it to make it work for him
and his particular dilemma.
And he ended up wearing that for quite a long time
and that allowed his shin to heal.
But he said short of that,
he felt like he might just snap his leg and pass
that's how much pain he was in.
And he was willing to do that.
Like, this is, he will snap his leg before he quits.
But the brace allowed that to heal.
But then it created an imbalance
that started to cause problems in his hip
on the other side.
Radiated to his hip and then he got in a bike rack
that would have taken somebody out
most people out, they wouldn't even have finished.
And he didn't even want a day.
The one riding in front of him got something caught
in her spokes I believe toppled over.
He got lucky there,
cause that could have been a lot worse.
And that's why those guys in the yellow shirts
are so important and Casey and Aaron has winged, man.
They're out there protecting him,
policing the Peloton and making sure
that people get a little bit of juice
from James from time to time.
But also making sure that there's a little bit
of a barrier to protect him
when there's so many people out there participating,
they wanna have a little bit of a moment with James.
And that could be very destabilizing
or distracting for this guy
who's trying to do something very hard.
So in addition to just physically,
barricading him, they also have to be politicians.
Like they're both very gregarious character.
Great guys.
They're amazing.
Aaron is a very gifted cyclist, Casey.
I mean, obviously can do the riding,
but Casey is more than a runner.
And his talking to everybody
ell me your name.
Like if he saw somebody getting too close or hogging,
all the time he would have to go in there
and nicely trying to distract people away from him.
I mean, that's a skill on its own.
It is and on day 99 though,
he seemed relaxed like on day 99, it felt like,
he didn't, he wasn't worried about he,
they knew they needed to make a bubble for day 100.
But Casey was so chill on the marathon.
I started calling it the marathon,
not the run because that's what it was.
And it's not really a walk like you said,
it's more like a march.
So on the marathon, he was like super relaxed on day 99
I was able to talk with him for awhile,
but then day 100, we're there and it's he decides
he goes, so the average speed on the bike
for most of it has been the pool was the same two minutes,
a hundred on the two minutes, like you said, 40 of those.
And then the ride,
he was mostly keeping it like at 19 miles per hour,
kind of as the average pace
and Aaron was monitoring his pulse rate
and keep making sure it was around one 20, which is crazy.
I mean, like it altitude.
And then, but the next day they fired up that pace
to about 25 miles an hour.
I think it was just under 25 miles an hour.
So they were hauling and then for the first time,
since day five, he was gonna run the whole marathon
and they go, and we caught them at one point
and ran with them for a little bit I stopped
and interviewed some people,
but what was the pace like 10 minutes, a little under.
When we were running on day 100.
It wasn't fast,
but he was running for the first time in a very long time.
And it was a very hot day.
It was very hot day so we run...
And what's the altitude, like 6,000.
I think its just under 5,000.
And or around 550 maybe.
So he was probably running 930, 10 minute pace.
And so then you and I break out and we're thinking,
because we're not running the whole thing with them.
And we figure we want to get to the high school
for the finish.
And so we do that.
We go to the high school for the finish
and all of a sudden, I'm talking to Lucy
who paused to recognize Lucy Lawrence,
who unbelievable her while her dad's doing this.
And she's managing the entire social media
and the PR and she's 18.
And she graduated high school within that period of time,
just before, like he finished with not just,
her diploma, but with an AA degree,
like the equivalent of a two years of college.
And for those who enjoyed this whole experience,
on James Instagram, that's all Lucy,
like she produced this entire virtual event.
She was running social for James,
meanwhile, coordinating relationships with sponsors
and also all the merchandise stuff that they were doing.
We were out running and on day 91.
And she's like, you got to do a sponsor spot
for this company.
And she's like, here's what you need to say
and she's literally like PR I was like,
you should go to Hollywood and produce movies.
Like she was so honest she is like, no,
you're not doing it right, you got to do it like this.
And we need this now, like bossing him around.
She if you're a brand out there
who needs somebody to run social,
she is who you're looking for.
Unbelievable how committed she was to this
and what an incredible job and a challenge.
And so, anyway, I'm kind of like checking with her
to see how he's doing.
And she finally, she gets a message
and we realized that James is actually having trouble.
So from mile 19,
his legs would stop working just all of a sudden..
Just to back up for a second here
when I ran the first six miles with him on that day.
And he had told me on day 91,
that he was gonna bust a move on day 100 and lay it out.
He shows up with, the fancy running shoes.
He's good to go on day 100 starts out
with a jog we're running lightly.
I could tell he didn't really want to interact with anybody,
but I did get a couple quick moments with him.
And I said, are you still planning on dropping
the hammer today?
And he said, at mile 20,
I'm gonna drop the hammer like that was the plan.
He was gonna lay it out and I said, how do you feel?
He says, I feel fantastic.
It's like, all right, good to go.
So, yes, after six miles, I've pulled out,
you and I went to lunch,
then we go to the high school and we're helping them set up.
There's gonna be this big to-do
when it comes into this,
that high school is enormous, by the way,
gigantic with this huge football field and stadium.
And we help set up like a finish line
and all that kind of stuff.
And then sorry to interrupt.
No, and so then we were just kind of hanging out
and then I get wind what's happening.
And I'm like, I got to get there
and so I start kind of jogging up to
where they're gonna come down
off that kind of a city bike trail.
Cause they would do out and back,
two different outbacks normally.
But this time they were coming off that trail
that they do these out and backs on.
And then you call me,
you lost track of me and I'm like,
and all of a sudden you cut to you
and I running up to the marathon.
So Lucy sent you a little video clip, he was literally...
Saying extra when she first got it
and then I'm like, I got to get there.
So we went up and we get up there maybe a mile
from the finish or something
and mile and a half and he starts,
this minute we see him,
he has another one of those episodes.
And we saw like three or four times
where his wing men were actually catching him.
Or he would have fallen on his face--
He was passing out and stumbling over his feet
like losing consciousness.
So the plan...
Wasn't, but I think he might've been.
Well I don't know that he's the best narrator.
He's an unreliable narrator of his own experience
in that moment, because he was so out of it.
So the idea of like dropping the hammer,
cause in the 50, 50, 50,
he was drilling it like the last marathon.
And he was finishing with like 6630 miles
for the last 10 K or something like that.
I think he wanted to repeat that performance.
It was a really hot day.
One of the things we talked about was,
why did he start this thing
when it was literally snowing and sleeting and so cold?
When you're built like that,
you're not gonna do well in heat.
Like he doesn't have the thin body composition
that allows his core temperature to cool down quickly.
Heat affects him disproportionately,
I think in part, because of his bulk.
And he knew that the heat was gonna be a problem for him.
And that's why he started it as,
in the winter months and the way that he did.
And he was sort of reaping that on that final day
where the heat I think was really catching up to him.
But yeah he never stopped running
he didn't walk, he kept running.
He would pull it together and start together.
And then he gets in and he does four laps around the oval
and you were right right there
and the first couple of those,
and I broke off and just try to chase him down.
Like everybody run one lap
and then it was only friends
and supporters or something like that.
And I was gonna pull out,
but Lucy and Sonny were like, no, you should go.
So I was able to kind of run behind the wing man
and take a little bit of video of that I shared.
And then the last lap he did by himself.
But he did the last two laps, apparently,
according to his watch, he did sub seven minute pace.
So he did get a little taste.
And this is after like almost collapsing,
half dozen times at least.
Unbelievable performance I call that like,
that's one of the great athletic performance
you'll ever see and the crowd's roaring
there's over a thousand people.
They thought there would be 2000
it might've been close to that by the end.
It was definitely over a thousand.
Fishing a little bit earlier,
they were expecting about 2000 people.
I would say there's probably maybe a thousand
or something like that I'm not a very good judge,
but that whole grain sand was packed.
(overlapping conversations)
And it was so exhilarating and amazing to see him conclude,
this chapter in his life.
And then he gets up moments later and gives a speech
and he's regaling people and like, he came back to life.
You would've thought this guy's getting carried out
on a stretcher he is going to the hospital.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
He gives a 10 minute speech
and then spends the next two hours signing autographs
and taking pictures of people on his feet.
I know.
Unbelievable.
But he also had told me,
they had told me that there's gonna be a day one-on-one
and I was flying out that you flew out.
He told me that too.
So that was planned, he wanted to spring it on people.
But obviously, he already had a kit made up.
So, I knew he was gonna do that.
The match was strong, the match game was strong.
I mean a new kit every day are you kidding me?
I can't imagine what their house looks like,
which is boxes.
I wouldn't want to be responsible for shipping,
all that stuff out.
Great designs, the wing man,
the wing man bike kit is fabulous.
I love it.
So doesn't tell anybody, except, you know,
obviously his supporters and his family,
that he's gonna do this and wakes up the next day
and just blows people's minds by doing another one,
just with just basically went to the pool by himself.
And then his wing man,
and a couple of friends joined him for the last day
to just put the nail in the coffin to any doubters
and to really emphasize and underscore the point
that when you achieve,
even when you achieve such an outlandish goal,
there you can actually still do more.
I actually was able to swim
with them in that morning.
A couple of lanes over, he they did,
he did the first section of the swim by himself.
And then I was able to,
they allowed me to get in there and I swam maybe 1500
or something with them.
Did he have any words for you
about your Goggle equipment?
(laughs)
You might be surprised he was focused on the task at hand.
(laughing)
He had something else in his mind.
That one thing I did wanna ask you about though.
You got a lot of love out there on the course.
It's true.
A lot of people were like, I know that laugh.
Wait, is that Adam?
In addition to this being your first field assignment,
since before COVID,
we're here on the one-year anniversary,
it's really the first time that you've ventured out
into the world outside of Los Angeles.
So you got a little bit of taste,
a little taste of audience, love a podcast fans out there,
Some Rich Roll shine on me.
So it was good, I love that.
That was the coolest thing for me,
having you get recognized
for doing this thing here on the mic
that was really, really awesome.
The first time that's really happened
I mean, it was disorienting at times, but in a good way.
And I appreciate the audience
and this position I'm in right now.
So the seat and it was, that is like for you too I mean,
that is like the exact plate, even,
what's cool about it
is even promoting what James had been doing from day one.
And so it's not surprising
that there was such an intersection there
because like, part of the reason Said Saeed was there
was because you told him about James Lawrence.
Cause I was doing podcasts with him a long time ago.
I've been talking about him forever.
I still feel like media is dropping the ball
in terms of giving this guy some love.
You know, I think this sort of eclipsed,
any kind of mainstream attention,
I'm delighted that the New York Times Green Light
you going out there and doing a story.
And I look forward to that story coming out.
But on the whole,
aside from a couple like sort of local news stories,
there hasn't been that much attention
as sports illustrated wrote an article on it.
I was really glad to see that they acknowledged
what he had done, but when we were on,
but they weren't all day when we were,
they weren't there, nobody else had showed up
except for you but on when we were there on the final day
and we're at the high school and on the football field,
I got wind that this Washington post article
had come out about James,
that I want to pull up right now.
Which we both kind of read together,
standing on the football field.
Well Sunny, who's James's wife comes up to me and says,
don't do what the Washington post did.
I'm like, wait, what?
Can we read this thing?
So we read this article,
it's titled Through Pain and Controversy,
the Iron Cowboy chase's 100 triathlons in 100 days.
The first, how does this open?
The second paragraph did they, oh yeah.
So when it's describing James,
the paragraph introducing and basically says billing himself
as the "Iron Cowboy", Lawrence aims to conquer 100
full distance triathlons in 100 days.
And this art,
which is kind of like a little bit of a backhanded,
not so nice way of introducing him,
this article proceeds to Chronicle
what he's attempting to do,
but it does it in a very kind of condescending way
and chooses to focus on things
that I think are not the point.
There's no mention of the community
and all these people that have come out,
this journalist didn't show up on the debt,
for any aspect of this,
to be boots on the ground who experienced
what was happening
and focused on things like, oh he takes an IV at night,
which is basically...
A couple of times a week.
To help himself recover,
which James has been extremely transparent about.
Basically tells you what he's doing and shows you
and says what's in the Iv.
And it's essentially the same thing
that you would get if you completed an Ironman
and went into the tent afterwards,
which is what a lot of people do at those races.
And then a bunch of other stuff
that just really is a distraction from,
what he was attempting to do without a lot of recognition
around just how extraordinarily difficult this is,
the kind of groundbreaking,
legendary aspect of doing something
that nobody had ever done before.
And I just thought it was lazy and uncool
I was like, why are you thought it was a hit piece?
And why even write this article?
I didn't understand it.
I can't speak for that reporter,
but most likely he would have loved to come out
and he probably just didn't get approved to come out.
And that's just a guest from me,
a guy sitting in a room, I have no idea
I have no connection to this reporter
or to the Washington post.
It focuses on criticism and controversy
with respect to his charity of choice.
And also some grumblings within the triathlon community
there was a bit of a controversy
when he did the 50, 50, 50,
because of weather conditions and logistics.
He was forced to do I don't know how,
like a marathon or two on an elliptical,
which was not his preference, which made people think,
well, he didn't really do this.
I think there was a couple of things
one was like, he did everything indoors
on a bad weather day.
And then the other thing,
he had an injury and he said,
and I think he did the marathon in elliptical
because as long as he's endorsed might not do that
witch or something like that, that's okay.
It gave people a reason to take them down a notch
and there's a snarkiness to all of this.
And I think one of them talks about why
(overlapping conversation)
Like what does why think of him doing these IVs?
And does this really count as a record?
Is this really a record at all?
The fact that the discussion is around whether
or not this is a record, like who cares?
I don't care if it's a record
who cares if it ends up in the Guinness book of world,
it's like, that's not the point.
The point is this guy went out and did something
unbelievably hard he did it with his friends.
He did it with whatever support that he could muster
and he impacted thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people around the world who are now rethinking
their own perception of personal capability.
And the fact that this article didn't acknowledge
any aspect of that, I think is irresponsible.
And it bummed me out that this article even existed,
to me it's really a story that should be
all about basically what the thing is called conquering,
impossible and getting this impossible thing
and the impact that it's had on other people.
And you see other athletes,
it's very telling in who's flocked
to kind of be a part of this thing.
And people from all backgrounds all over the country,
he's getting messages from all over the world.
Other athletes are super impressed.
That was the big thing.
Well, like Tommy Rivers came out,
who's recovering from cancer is still in his struggle
and got through six miles with James, which was huge.
But the other thing is that
because there was this controversy
with the 50, 50, 50 with the elliptical and whatnot,
he really wanted to, quiet all of that and put it to bed.
So that's one reason I think that he decided
to do a hundred and then do 101.
And along the way,
if you go to places like Slow-twitch which is notorious
for a cantankerous forum section
where people like to take people down a peg,
he basically turned the tide there
and now has essentially unanimous support
from the endurance and multi-sport community at large.
It's funny is that one thing he said
that was disappointing and the whole team was saying
is that the local triathlon community
did not turn out for him.
And they never really understood why during the 50,
he was getting a lot of support until this,
that elliptical thing happened.
And then I don't know what happened.
It fell apart, but in the 100,
they weren't showing up,
they weren't showing up to the swims
they weren't showing up to the bikes,
they weren't showing up to the runs.
The people that really showed up
were the cyclists in Lindon and around...
A lot of cyclists in that area.
Because they were doing something of a criterion.
In the middle of pacing, like a 14 mile loop,
they would do it like three or four times
they'd ride there and then they would do
they'd do the loop and then they'd ride back.
And so they would have like the leaders,
they would be in the Peloton kind of like you said,
in the cut, like the end,
this Arrowhead of riders would take turns
and they'd switch off and they'd go hard
and lead the Park and break wind.
And so the cyclists really were heroes
and then the everyday people
who turned up were heroes.
It is weird that the triathletes couldn't show up for him.
Yeah, they thought it was weird, but you know...
It's a weird cultural thing.
And it's weird and I understand like,
for whatever it is, when you see a story
that's duplicitous or has several aspects to it,
there's something about that, that's good.
But at the same time, yes, you could
there's this version of story
where a lot of people told the story
without getting into the controversy.
They just wanted to tell the story
of this guy doing this hard thing.
And some editors like the multi-pronged approach,
because it's a more nuanced story.
And it's a little bit more,
just something to chew on.
Personally I was just glad to be there
and witness it that last day,
that finish was remarkable to get up every day with him
and even for me, just to get up every day.
The pool was hard I mean, at 5:00 AM
and he's getting five hours of sleep and he was like,
the stuff that didn't get into my stories,
his sleep was not like you'd expect him just to collapse
and like sleep hard, like a rock for five hours.
He said he was having night terrors waking up screaming.
Yeah, he told me about that,
night terrors, sweating profusely, like his sleep score.
He had this Bio-Tracker thing
and he was getting terrible sleep scores.
So he would go home at the end of the day,
get on the massage table,
get worked on fall asleep on the massage table,
move to the couch, get the NormaTec boots on
and essentially fall asleep.
But he never slept deeply,
he would have crazy dreams,
he was sleepwalking somewhat night terrors.
I never had night terrors wacky,
then on top of the whole thing,
I wanna get into kind of where he's at now,
physically and emotionally,
he was telling me on day 91,
that he could that for a long time,
he hasn't been able to feel anything in his two of his toes
on his left foot, not the big toe,
but the two next to the big toe.
And he said, I'm probably gonna have to,
it's a nerve thing.
It probably has to do with his back
and his hip or something like that.
But he has no feeling in them
and they might have to get removed
and he was okay with that.
(chuckles)
It's his idea I think.
He's like, let's just get rid of them.
So the links to which this guy has gone.
The extent to please do not be confused
like this guy has taken his body to the brain.
And if you've been following him in the days
that have elapsed, since he's completed this,
you see somebody who's struggling right now.
He immediately came down to LA
and went to UCLA to have all these tests done.
They put them on the stationary bike.
He breaks the record.
I don't know what the record is in the hospital or whatever,
but whatever it was he broke it 6% body fat, but brain fog.
He's having trouble with his thinking and his speaking.
I think he's struggling a little bit,
kind of emotionally, existentially where...
He was on this great.
He was saying like,
he gets up in the morning and he just wanders around
He doesn't know what to do.
It's like his body is so traumatized
and was in this survival mode for so long.
And it's reckoning now with like, what comes next?
And we'll see, we'll see how that plays out.
Of course, I wanna get them back on the show,
but I'm not like, when he's ready,
he knows he has an open invitation here
and he knows how much I love him
and how much this audience loves and appreciates him.
So he knows he's welcome.
And when he's ready to come on,
we'll get him back on the show.
He told me that he can't even unpack it yet.
So the longer you wait actually might be better
in terms of unpacking some of the details.
He is incredibly gifted also at basically dropping
these wise speeches at the end of every day.
Like he's done this whole thing
and then he'll give
this inspirational five to 10 minute speech
at the end of every day.
Like he has a command on the power of
what he's doing and how it impacts other people.
And he's developing a greater and greater facility
or capacity to communicate that in a way
that's impactful to people as well.
So we love you, James, we wish you well,
we were proud and happy to be able to be there
to bear witness and to support you
as you completed this crazy thing.
So any final thoughts on that?
(overlapping conversation)
(chuckles)
I mean, you turned it in what's going on?
I mean, technically I'm in...
How is this newspaper function?
Apparently there's other stories out there.
I get sometimes antsy when stories get held,
especially when you are like them
and you want them out there
and I'm sure the Lawrence's family wants it too.
But the good thing about the New York Times
is the reach is great and their skill
at storytelling is great.
So it tends to land well, whenever it comes out,
I remember the Maya Gabeira story,
which is one of the best performing stories
I've done probably ever,
they held that for like two, three weeks or something.
And I was really antsy about that.
Did they tell you what the traffic is
that they give you analytics
on how well your story does
or how many people have read it.
No I get general kind of feeling from it though,
like it's, that's proprietary stuff
and I'm not on stuff there.
So I don't really ask for specific numbers
and they wouldn't be obligated
or it wouldn't be wise for them to tell me anyway.
So, but I have a good relationship with my editors there
and they let me know when things are going well.
And when it's pinging all over the world
and what's doing well.
So typically these things do do well.
They do better than the typical sports stories
that they run.
Well, we need a good follow-up to the woman
who fell two miles to earth
and this might just be the thing.
I hope so I hope people like it.
And I think it's an interesting read
I get into what he consumed on day 99 in this,
in the story and his food intake,
which is worth I'm not gonna tea
I'm not going to spoil that, that's a good one.
We're recording this on Monday, June 21st
it will publish on June 24th
perhaps in that intervening day,
the story will come out if it has,
or it hasn't if it has but of course we'll link it up
in the show notes and in the description on YouTube.
But if it hasn't come out by that point,
we'll be sure to let everybody know
and direct attention to that.
Perfect.
Cool.
Well, let's take a quick break
and we'll be back with wins of the week
and my conversation with Jacob Frey.
And we're back Adam, let's do some Wins of the Week.
Let's go, what you got?
First up, we have the great lakes jumper.
I love the great lake jumper.
Another New York's Times story
this is the story of a man
who jumped into lake Michigan every day for nearly a year.
That's literally the headline of the article.
I'm gonna pull it up right here.
I love this piece, you love it too?
I do love it, I love it.
I love it for a couple of reasons.
So this is a guy who basically lives in Chicago
and at the start of the pandemic
was struggling like a lot of people.
And I don't know what came over him,
but he decided that he was gonna jump into Lake Michigan.
And that day turned into a second day,
turned into a streak that he has stuck with
for over a year at this point.
Really jumping in year round into lake Michigan,
he makes, I guess he makes like hand stencils t-shirts
for bands and travels around to festivals
and when all that went away,
he didn't know what to do with himself,
but he has these relationships with musicians
and he would have musicians come out
and play live at like 10:30 in the morning
when he, well he would jump into the lake
and he was sharing this on Instagram
and everybody just kind of fell in love with this guy.
53 year old guy what's his name?
Dan O'Conor
And Julie Bossman did the story.
I think it's a great story because it's like,
what I love about it and Julie gets into this in the story.
One of the reasons I love it is,
is that we've been taking ourselves way too seriously.
His got tired of politics, he got tired of the bullshit
and he just needed something pure.
Here's a little, let me play this like Instagram clip
of him jumping in.
Because this is what he would do,
he would literally jump in
he would do cannonballs, all sorts of things.
I don't know if we can get the sound on this probably not.
This is his Cannonball.
Here he is.
41 degree air, 44 degree water good for him.
There's another one of him jumping in the ice.
There he is doing a flip with the musician
and where's the one of him in the ice.
That's crazy he doesn't chip away.
He had to chip away.
22 degrees out
And he had to chip away
at ice and it's not whim Hafi
and there's nothing optimizing about this.
No, it's just joy.
It's just pure joy and like, I love this
cause like, this is what we need.
We don't need this unnecessary counterproductive,
like jabbering at each other.
We just need some dude willing to jump in.
(laughing)
Flopping into the end of the water...
Every day to remind us that we're all human.
Life is not, sometimes this is what you have to do.
I had a period of time in my life,
I think it was 2005 where like things I didn't,
I felt like I didn't know where I was in my life.
And that's what I started to do.
It was like February or something.
And I started to do every day for 40 days
cause I was like big into cooling yoga at the time
and as Guru Singh says,
sometimes every after 40 days,
this cell where the cells in your blood,
you have fully recycled.
So like you've kind of recharged
that's why they do 40 day meditations in Kundalini yoga.
And so it was kind of like that
I would walk down from my apartment
to the beach and jump in the ocean
and just swim past the waves
and bop around a little bit and come back.
I did every day it turned out to be like 60 days
by the time I was done it did help.
Like and I wasn't open water swimmer at the time
I wasn't doing a lot of that.
And so I was certainly wasn't in love
with the cold water yet.
And so there's something about the power
of surrendering to the, like that ritual.
Sometimes you need a ritual like that
to like get your mind.
Yeah I mean, what's not to love about this guy.
Look at him, but I love it.
Just floating in the lake.
Sometimes that's what life's about.
Not this, not what we have going on here.
There's a couple of things I wanted to mention
about this though, because there's a few analogies here.
We want it to draw attention to
one of which is it's reminiscent
of what the happy pear guys have been doing
for a couple of years at this point,
people who listen to the podcast are familiar
with David and Stephen Flynn
they live in Greystones Ireland,
which is about an hour south of Dublin,
they run a veg shop.
They're prolific on social media,
sharing this message of healthy, vibrant living,
super fit, identical twins.
And a couple of years ago,
they just started jumping into the Irish Sea
every morning at Dawn, like,
and that became their routine
and they would share it on Instagram and Instagram stories
and slowly but surely people
started showing up to do this with them.
And now there are days where hundreds of people show up
to do this and they do it year round.
It doesn't matter how cold it is.
And then they all congregate on the beach
and share a bowl of porridge and have breakfast
and tell stories.
And sometimes there's a campfire
and they've really created this amazing movement
and community around just getting
into cold water every single day.
Greystones Ireland.
Greystones yeah, it's a little village about an hour.
It's sort of a suburb,
but its own thing about an hour south of Dublin.
So those guys have been doing their version
of this phrase for quite a while.
I was there for an early incarnation of it
and that water is cold, man.
I got to tell you.
So you did do it?
Yeah I've done it with them.
Secondly, there's something about this idea of streaks,
like the idea that you're gonna do it every single day,
no matter what,
like the happy pear guys like this guy in Chicago,
which leads me to think about a guest
that's coming on this week.
How is Siddha bay?
Who is on this extraordinary run day streak?
He's run over 1400 days consecutively
without missing a single day,
including being the first black guy to run across
the United States completed a couple of weeks ago.
So he's coming on the show this week.
I'm not sure when we're gonna air that,
but I'm sitting down with him
and I think this idea of streaks, it's like,
no matter what this guy's gonna run
and no matter what that dude's gonna jump
into lake Michigan and the happy pear guys
are gonna get into the Irish Sea.
And when you prioritize it
and create momentum around that consistency,
look what can happen.
It's kind of an amazing, powerful, mystical thing.
It is mystical cause it's not about trying to get ahead
or get anywhere other than just do that one thing.
And that that's the power of it, you know?
It's surprising with the guy in Chicago
that there are people showing up to do it with him.
There were like, I...
They are not a huge crowds.
Just towards the end,
I think he had like a...
One dude with a cookout or yeah,
He had a couple bands,
but I liked that Hellah is coming on.
He's also he's I saw him commenting,
supportive message on Iron Cowboy Instagram.
It was cool to see that.
I mean, even though we're in cowboy 100 days same idea.
Consistency, streaks momentum.
I've changed a diaper like...
See a theme.
How many days in a row is that now?
You've been breathing consistently for many days in a row.
We all do things consistently
without thinking about what can we add on?
And when you look at it,
when you just make it the priority
and you orient your life around that,
these things that seem daunting, suddenly become rote.
And when you take them in bite size chunks,
just, I don't have to worry about tomorrow, just today.
How am I gonna get my run in today?
How am I gonna jump in like Michigan today?
That's all it is.
That's it man.
Couple more wins of the week.
You've got I want to shout out Jason Caldwell
and this great Pacific race that's happening right now.
It's a 2,400 nautical mile event of rowing
that started on May 31st
where Jason and his team of four,
along with a couple other teams are attempting
to row from San Francisco to Hawaii, to Honolulu,
I guess only 22 teams and 60 people
have ever completed this race.
You did some research on that site.
Looks like it launched in 2014.
Yeah, it's held every two years launched in 2014,
the record was set of 39 days that we said yeah,
39 days in 2016, the pandemic delayed last year's race.
So now they're on to odd years.
You can put in your application for 2023 right now Rich.
That's something I won't be doing,
but I've got mad respect for Jason and his teammates
for tackling this thing.
The first half for the race
apparently saw some big conditions out there
and the season has been glass here lately.
They're on day 22.
Is it 21 or 20?
The world record is 39 days.
So they're well into it at this point.
They're on day 22 yes, yes, yes.
What's interesting about this event
is you would think if you just got
the four best rowers in the world,
you would crush it.
But that's not really how this works.
You certainly need people who are very good at rowing,
but what's more important is finding people
who are experienced in adversity and adventure sports.
Like how are you gonna deal with being wet all the time
and having your sleep disrupted
and vomiting because of the way,
like all the conditions that get thrown at you
and the variables, et cetera.
So one of the things,
Jason is an extraordinarily accomplished adventure athlete.
This guy has crossed then a bit desert,
he's rode the Atlantic twice.
The first time he broke the American record,
despite two of his crew being airlifted for medical reasons,
then he came back with a new team
and broke the world record.
He's done all kinds of things in different terrains
and environments.
And he's got these other teammates,
Angus Collins, Gus Barton and Dunkin Roy,
The same guys are back?
I don't know.
I should do a little bit more research on this,
but these guys are not all like,
collegiate accomplished rowers.
Jason's got obviously a background in rowing,
but I think there's a diversity of experience
and background that these guys all bring
that allow this kind of this to function optimally,
as a team sort of experience.
The video on of his Atlantic race
is it was really telling,
I don't think it's the same three guys
from the Atlantic race, but the guy,
one of the guys from the Atlantic race
who was the best rower,
who was actually not used to rowing an open ocean.
And so he had really bad seasickness
the first 24 something hours.
And it looked like
it was gonna be another airlift situation,
but they were able to stabilize him
and get him some rest.
And then he became a real valuable asset
just crushing it down the stretch
there in these kayaks similar
to how Colin or Brady and his team.
Its the same kind of boat.
Kayak is the wrong word
I mean, these are large boats.
So two people, I think two people
are rowing at a time and the other two are sleeping
they do these shifts.
So they're literally going around the clock too.
Two at a time, it's for most teams have four people.
The other two teams in the water,
we should note are all female teams,
there's the ocean sheroes,
which are hot on the tail of the guys.
I don't know how far they're probably good ways back.
But if you look at the tracker,
they look like they're hot on their tray tales,
but they're doing great.
I mean, they're right there.
And then the girls who dare are having
a little bit more trouble, they're going south.
It looks like they're going south
to catch a Western current.
So they're still in it though
they're still going, they're in Baja or, I mean,
both these they've gone a long way.
They're already very south and west
and they're well on their way to breaking a record here.
And the ocean sheroes might actually get
that 39 day record too.
They're cruising and there are great follow
also on Instagram too.
So I just wanted to put this on people's radar
as this story rapidly unfolds,
you can follow it best place to follow.
It is on Instagram at lat 35 racing
lat the number three five racing
where there's a bunch of updates here
and you kind of pay attention and keep tabs on these guys.
And the great Pacific race.
We'll have a link to click if you want to see their tracker.
And then you can see how the three teams are doing right.
But so basically there are three teams,
four men and seven women attempting to do this.
I just, sometimes I think that's really cool that like,
there's that many bad-ass women out there going forward too.
It's very cool, so if they make it safely,
we'll see if we can get Jason on the podcast.
Tell us all about it.
So this is the point where we were gonna pivot
to Jacob Frey,
but there's one more thing that we discussed this morning
that you wanted to talk about.
Should we, or should we...
No let's do it, why not?
Let's do it.
So go for it.
Well, we this a Supreme court case
just got a verdict, just got ruled on
a Supreme court case about amateurism and American sport.
And basically it was about the NCAA,
which rules all college athletics.
And they were trying to preserve things.
The status quo,
which is you have to be an amateur to play college sports.
So that means even though these athletes
in cases of football and baseball
who make millions and hundreds of millions of dollars
for universities and for the NCA,
they don't get paid anything.
So then when they do take a benefit,
maybe under the table,
they're somehow painted as corrupt
and they've done and they're suspended.
And the burden of that is on them.
And often they might come from families
that don't have a lot of money
and don't have a lot of opportunity outside sport,
especially when you're talking about football and bat
and basketball and largely black.
And so the burden always falls on them
and the funny thing about amateurism
is it's always been used as a cudgel
against people that didn't have money
or didn't have options.
Even the Olympics,
they used to be thought of as if you're an amateur athletic.
There's some amateur athletes, somehow that's more pure.
And so we should hold that up,
but that often kept Olympians impoverished
or even all the way back to Duke and Jim Thorpe,
which we talked about in the last roll on
those guys both came from backgrounds
where they didn't have a lot of money
and didn't have a lot of opportunity.
And Duke was able to be taken care of by people in Hawaii
that allowed him to keep his amateurism.
Otherwise he would have been disgraced
and had his metal strip, just like Jim Thorpe,
who was arguably the best athlete of his era.
And so that's been hanging over the NCAA
and slowly but surely people
have been trying to get rid of it.
And the Supreme court unanimously ruled
that that amateurism cloak is gone.
You can't pay athletes, whatever,
it's not open market like free agency
and professional sports,
but you are gonna be able to give more benefits.
There's gonna be less limits on that
there'll be stipends that will be allowed,
there'll be all sorts of things
that will give all athletes in every sport,
basically opportunities that they didn't have before.
The way I look at this,
is that it's just a crack,
the doors starting to open
because this is a very narrow ruling.
It's not busting open the flood gates so that these
athletes can start profiting off their likenesses
and their social media and get paid like professionals.
It's a very narrow application of a particular law
that allows them to get compensation
for education-related stuff.
Like it's complicated but the point being that,
this is a small piece in a much larger puzzle,
and I'm glad that this is happening.
I wish that it was going further and faster
because I think it's preposterous
that these college athletes are not being compensated
while the Institute is enriching itself to,
an extreme extent and so much of how these colleges operate
functions on taking advantage of these athletes
to sort of learn, like sort of GERD their coffers.
And I just find it in 2021
to be exploitive and extremely distasteful
and I think more importantly,
when you look at this more broadly,
from the perspective of what are colleges doing
in general and where have we lost our way?
I think there is an argument to be made
for shining a light on the kind of scammy nature
to which the university system and colleges
in general are exploiting,
not just athletes, but students in general.
This is something that Scott Galloway,
who's a professor of business at NYU
and also kind of a YouTube and podcast star
has been ranting about for a while,
but he makes some really good points,
which is basically that higher education
has been squeezing students for 30 years.
Tuition has exploded, it's up 1400% since 1978,
which is 15.
It's a 15 X increase in the last 40 years.
And the tuition to salary ratio used to be 25% meaning
you pay this certain tuition,
but you can expect to earn this much
when you get out into the workplace.
But that 25%, 25 times max,
I mean is now dwindled to 1.4 X.
So these numbers are out of whack,
meanwhile, housing costs have escalated
from 2.8 times once average starting salary
to 10 times one's salary.
So you can't make it work.
No.
And these colleges,
to coin Scott's phrasiology are essentially luxury brands
that are driven by artificial scarcity
to create irrational margins.
And the colleges are drunk on this scarcity
because they can create such massive demand for entrance.
Meanwhile, they have these billion dollar endowments
and you know, when universities used to,
wants aspire to be public servants,
they're now just these brands.
And it doesn't make sense
when you have these massive endowments,
tuition costs are insane.
And even when you look at someone like Scott
or any typical university professor,
and you compare how it breaks down
in terms of what a student has to pay
to attend a certain class versus
what that college professor is being paid
to teach that class,
it's also completely out of whack.
It's something like a 90% commission on professors.
So the point being that the exploitation is extreme
with the athletes,
but it's also exploitation across the board with students.
And I think COVID presented an opportunity
for us all to re-imagine what the system could look like
because driving this artificial scarcity,
really doesn't make sense anymore.
Like if you fail has an entering class of,
I don't even know what it is, 2000, 3000 people,
why can't that be 50,000 people at a much reduced tuition
price where you're in this hybrid virtual,
learn from home situation.
Like if you really want to be a public servant
and if your priority is to provide higher education
at a cost effective point to the most number of people
were capable of doing that.
But these universities want to protect the fact that
they are luxury brands
and that that's established by making it
rare in the sense that a diamond is rare.
It's great, all great points.
I think Gladwell did one in one of his first seasons
of revisionist history.
He did something I think he profiled like Vassar or Smith.
One of those two, the only like high-end college
that actually uses its endowment for the students
to actually get poor students to come in
and pays their entire way out of their endowment,
which is what you're basically advocating.
And it's not just exploiting students
cause it's a splitting all families
because who's paying for,
sometimes it's the student getting into debt.
Sometimes it's the family themselves,
but having to save and scrape together money
over the course of an entire working life
and then put it into the hands of these,
white tie, white shoe.
The idea that you're going out
into the workplace straddled with extraordinary debt
and an era where we're bailing out airlines
and car companies and the bankers,
to the extent that we're doing
it just becomes really unpalatable.
It does and that's what has driven
this incredible distrust,
which we is a great way to pivot,
to kind of the guy you're sitting
in one of the toughest positions in politics.
His job was probably the hardest job in politics
other than maybe the president during a pandemic.
And because of all these things that are true
because of all these flaws in systems
that we've always kind of figured ran
the world and then the exposure of that,
and then the backlash against that
and the outrage kind of spiral that happens,
there's such low trust in institutions.
And partly because of what you're saying,
cause they ex you know, there's exploitation.
And they've betrayed our mission statements
and the people that rely on them.
So then what if you are a mayor,
cut from the same cloth as like a liberal
kind of like a, not to compare them to Obama,
but someone who like running a hope
and change type campaign
And wants to then take the mantle
of an institution that is derided at this time.
What a difficult...
You're in an impossible situations,
because Jacob Frey really is of that political ilk.
He is a hope and change progressive,
who comes into this situation, looking to,
like sort of build bridges in a bipartisan way.
And he finds himself in a situation
in which his city is literally at war with itself
and on the precipice of total implosion.
And no matter what he does,
he will be derided and criticized.
He's either not progressive enough
or he's way out of bounds, progressive every measure
and every move that he takes
is under the microscope of the world,
because all attention is focused on Minneapolis,
in the wake of George Floyd
and the trial and everything going on there.
So the pressure could not be more enormous
on that individual.
And what interested me about him and the reason
to speak to him was not to have an in-depth conversation
about policy and his politics,
but more to understand the human being
who's weathering these kinds of hits
and the kind of guy
who has gotten into Twitter beefs with Donald Trump.
And I feel, if I give him a charitable interpretation,
he's really trying to do the right thing
and you may disagree or agree
with how he's trying to do that.
But maintaining peace in a city poised to explode
is a tall order.
You have to set matters to rights,
you've got to acknowledge the wrongs,
you've got to make the appropriate changes,
and you have to do all of this under the spotlight.
As I mentioned of the world
where half the people think he's doing not enough
and the other half think that he's bowing too much.
So the conversation that I wanted to have with him
was really about that, not politics,
but how one manages the stress and pressure
that he has had to shoulder and what it feels like
to have to make really important, difficult.
And at times no wind decisions
while the world watches.
And also the fact that this guy is not for nothing,
probably the most accomplished runner
in elected office in America.
That's right.
That was another big piece of.
What an unbelievable runner this guy is,
this is a guy who, in addition to being mayor of Minneapolis
is a former professional runner.
He trained with Dez Linden back in the day,
he was repped by Saccone.
He got fourth in the marathon
at the 2007 Pan-American games in Rio,
where he ran two 16 crazy for the marathon.
And then in 2008, he outright won the Austin marathon.
Like he didn't win the amateur
like he won the whole thing.
This is the mayor of Minneapolis
he's a young guy, he's got a baby.
It's kind of an extraordinary situation.
So of course, when the opportunity presented itself
to talk to this guy while I was in Minneapolis,
of course, I'm gonna take that opportunity
because Brogan's friends with him
and set that whole thing in motion.
And I think it's important to note that,
look Jacob came to the interview in good faith.
Like and I really appreciate him taking the time
to talk to me.
But for all the reasons we just mentioned,
the guy's in a pickle, like it's not in his interest
to have like an emotional, you know,
vulnerable conversation with me about his life.
Like he's trying to hold everything together.
It's still is so..
What's the latest?
well, here we are in June,
but on June 3rd, they dismantled George Floyd Square.
There's an article about this in the New York Times
that I can pull up.
And they did it two things about this.
First of all, they didn't announce it ahead of time.
Just one Dawn on the third Dawn Dawn on the third,
they started dismantling the barriers and they,
secondly, they did it in partnership
or cooperation with the Agape Movement.
Which is a community organization
that I was able to encounter.
Like I met with some of these people
when I visited George Floyd square,
got to know a couple of them.
That's the guy from the Agape Movement is the dude
who said, what is your podcast, dude?
That's the guy.
He was the Agape one of the Agape dudes.
And so the Agape Movement has taken some hits
for cooperating with this from liberal minded folk
who did not want these barriers taken down.
So it's controversial.
The Agape Movement is funded by the city.
I think they got a couple of hundred thousand dollars.
So that of course, caused some criticism.
And if you're Jacob,
like there's this balance between recognizing
and acknowledging and memorializing
the importance of everything
that has transpired in Minneapolis,
but there's also a countervailing force
and quite a few people who want the road back open
and the businesses that are inside that square,
who want to reopen as well.
How do you make the right call?
How do you do what's right?
Is there a right answer to how to resolve?
And these are, that's just one of,
probably several types of issues that,
Mayor Frey has to deal with every single day.
So I've always said whoever was in office in 2020,
and as an administrator mayor, governor, president,
I would like to see how many keep their jobs.
It's not going to be many.
It's so rough.
The mayor job is an interesting one though,
because you actually have a lot of power.
You have more power as a mayor
to actually do stuff and get stuff done.
Then most elected officials.
Didn't I said he just take an ambassador powers(laughs)
I don't think he was expecting a win.
Well, we got a lot more to come.
So why don't we cut it there
and good it now to my conversation with Mayor Jacob Frey.
Well, super nice to meet you, man.
I appreciate you taking time out of your busy life
to sit down and I'm excited to talk to you, man.
I mean, first of all,
I'm glad that I'm not walking in your shoes
right now I can't imagine the level of stress
and strain that your life delivers to you on a daily basis.
It's gotta be a lot to just shoulder everything
that this city throws at you.
So how do you, like,
what is your routine to just maintain your equanimity
throughout everything?
It is heavy, there's no doubt about it.
And it's both not about me,
which I fully recognize.
I mean this hundred year in the making reckoning
around racial justice is not about me specifically as mayor,
but obviously I'm very involved
as the mayor of Minneapolis.
And you feel that weight every single day,
I have a little bit of a mantra
that I tell myself every morning when I wake up,
the first thing I tell myself
is find a way that's always been my mantra.
I have find a way for whatever it is
that you're trying to figure out,
whatever problem you're trying to solve,
whatever form of justice
or equity you're trying to accomplish, it's find a way.
But then there's a few simple principles
that I live by beyond that.
And sometimes when you're going through
the most strenuous difficulty and that's all you can do,
it's first tell the truth,
be honest and no matter what,
second you try to do what's right.
And obviously what is right
is oftentimes up for debate.
And then the last thing is you just try your hardest
and you keep putting one foot in front of the other
and that's all you can do.
So it's that mantra
and then of course it's running.
I mean, running has always been
some form of release for me
and has become more of a release
since I stopped doing it seriously.
Yeah I want to talk about the running.
Let's just get into that now.
I can't imagine there's anybody
in elected office in the U.S
who's a more accomplished runner than yourself.
I think you have that crown don't you?
two 16 marathoner.
I mean, it's unbelievable.
Yeah I don't know it's possible.
I feel like lately any way,
runners have been getting more and more involved
in different causes, social justice, politics, et cetera,
who knows?
That was certainly my previous life.
Pro runner and was competing as a pro all the way
through law school or part of law school.
Yeah I, well, so I graduated college
I very soon thereafter moved out to join
the Hanson's Olympic Development Program with Brooks.
(overlapping conversation)
She was Desi Davila at the time.
And then she married our buddy Ryan
and it was a wonderful experience out in the Hanson's.
They've got this amazing program where,
you just get up and you start running
with a big group of people
that are doing exactly the same thing.
And it becomes a whole lot easier to run very high mileage
because you have that kind
of camaraderie associated with it.
So I did that for a year and a half or so,
and then went back and probably
had my very best running years of my entire career
while I was in law school.
So the Pan-Am games
was that while you were in law school?
It was that's?
That's crazy balancing those two things at that time.
Well, for me it was almost a sense of relief
because once I was in law school,
there was another outlet for energy.
There was another way of thinking. I mean,
when I was out in Michigan,
I was running, I was eating, I was sleeping
and that was pretty much it.
And to have another concentration
was actually kind of nice for me
because I wasn't entirely dependent on a successful race
to get a paycheck, you know?
And I think that in many respects was helpful
and freeing in a way that actually led
to some of my best running,
but it was also monotonous because, and lonely,
and I'm an extrovert I love people.
I love talking to people
I'm so honored to talk to,
the great philosopher Rich Roll right now,
who happens to be in our city, which is incredible,
but you spend hours and hours in the books
and studying for a law school exam.
And then you spend hours and hours out doing 15
and seven double days, which is boring.
Do you do that on your own or were you running
with a group like a crew when you were in law school?
The vast majority of it was on my own.
I had a slew of buddies that I'd get out for runs
with, there was a Kenyan team
that was training a bit there too,
that I would run occasionally with Villanova.
They had a great team well,
so occasionally I'd run with a guy or two from there.
But no, by and large, it was on my own.
And went William and Mary on a running scholarship.
I had I think it was a half scholarship
for most of the time, but yes.
Went to William and Mary and ran through college.
I was probably, I probably took it far too seriously,
almost at the time, but it was a wonderful spot as well.
And grew up in DC
Grew up in Northern Virginia.
I grew up in Bethesda.
There you go just to cross the Potomac High School.
What high school did you go to?
I went to Oakton High School.
Yeah, we had a hell of a team at the time.
Reston area?
Yeah, very nearby Reston,
actually in Reston Alan Webb who was just,
a year and a half or so younger than I was.
And so he was a training partner
through the most successful period
of my running career, which was around 2007.
And Alan was busy setting the American record
in the mile and he was the fastest person ever.
And I was training for the marathon
and which was my top year back in 2007 as well,
and so different events.
And he was obviously far more accomplished than I,
but a good buddy anyway.
Yeah, so you go to the, you make the Team USA,
Pan-American team 2007
that's where you run your PR right.
To two 16 and then you won the Austin Marathon,
like the year following.
Yup, Maybe six or seven months later.
I mean, the thing that I am most proud of,
in my running career is that,
well, let me take a step back.
My whole goal since I was like a ten-year-old
was to run for Team USA.
There is a tingle that you get
when you put on the USA Jersey
that you just don't get when you're aware and Saucony
or Brooks or some other brand.
And my goal was not just to represent Team USA,
but also run my absolute best.
And so I represented Team USA twice at the Pan Am Games
where I set my personal record.
And then at the Austin Marathon that I won.
And after that, I was, that was it,
I kinda got, I got done what I wanted to do.
And I had the USA Jersey, which I now brag about constantly
and I hang in my office at city hall.
And now that life is certainly a past history,
but I love talking about it still.
Yeah, of course.
Well running, but running still may,
maintains a huge place in your life.
It is, there's,
You're pretty trim.
So you're getting out there at least.
I think I'd be trimmed no matter what,
it's just kind of the physique or my biology,
but I mean, there's something so simplistic
and beautiful about running that I still really love.
And it's this direct correlation
between hard work and success.
That's why I originally fell in love with the sport.
If you work harder than the guy
that's standing next to you on the starting line,
you're probably gonna win.
And that's also kind of
what's incentivized me to get into politics,
was there is a lack of that direct correlation in society.
If I work hard,
there perhaps might be more of a direct correlation
with success in somebody else,
depending on where they grew up
or who their parents were,
or the socioeconomic background race,
all those things obviously contribute to the likelihood
of whether you see that direct correlation or not.
And that's part of it.
Yeah, running is, I mean,
certainly there's plenty of variables
that go into success, but it's relatively binary
in terms of that with the work in
kind of result out aspect of it.
And I'm interested in exploring like
how that spills into
how you think about policymaking and leading a city,
but at the same time, you're contending with,
a multitude of variables,
most of which you have no control over.
So the kind of work in result out thing
starts to break down a little bit in terms of,
how you kind of make hay with your job.
It does, but there are also external factors
associated with running as well.
I mean, people get busted up and hurt.
You know, performance is not necessarily dependent entirely
on your desire to succeed,
but your physical condition at the time,
sometimes you just have an off day,
but I mean, what I continue to hold pride in,
I often look back on is,
those moments when things were clicking beautifully
and running, and I mean,
those are some of the best days of my entire life.
I am so lucky in that the best run that I had,
race maintenance run, workout,
the best run in my entire life happened
to be my most important one, which was at the Pan-Am Games.
I mean, it was one of those days where I was wearing USA.
And so I was on, I was on top of the world.
I felt so good and I remember being about halfway
into the race and I was way back,
but where I was certainly predicted to be,
I was one of perhaps the last individuals
that get the entrance
and then you start to pass one after another, after another.
And then, the oxygen just starts falling into your lungs
your muscles are itching to run faster.
And I remember thinking to myself,
like as couldn't get any better,
I've never felt so good in my entire life.
And then it felt then it started raining,
which was a huge advantage for me.
I thought a one, cause I love running in the rain,
but two, I sweat like none other when I'm running
and so my shoes get really heavy.
So I figured this was the great evenor
because everybody else's shoes would be heavy too
and I thought this is just, everything was coming.
Those rare moments where everything just kind
of comes together in a perfect storm.
So yeah, you did the thing.
Did the thing called it a day,
moved on to the next thing.
Yeah, what's interesting
I think even more broadly about the relationship
between kind of running and what you do now
is that fundamentally you're an endurance athlete
and Minneapolis is in an endurance event right now.
And what you've learned as an endurance athlete
is it's about like the consistency, the persistence,
the just showing up, no matter what
it's like day in day out,
just keep showing up, keep showing up,
keep showing up sometimes on a wing and a prayer.
But you always know that if you're doing that,
you're taking out the best insurance policy
to get the outcome that you're seeking to get.
And so you're kind of mind, body
and spirit trained for that type of rigor.
Does that like resonate with that...
Absolutely it does. Yeah.
I mean, the way I think about it
is especially right now,
this last year has been like an ongoing high mileage phase
when you creep out or mile weeks, every week,
150 mile weeks every week.
You're creeping into that high mileage phase
and you're exhausted, your body's
is sometimes depressed emotionally.
Sometimes it's hard as well.
And the whole concept is that you put your body through
hell, you adapt to that hell.
Then you drop the mileage
and suddenly you feel like a million bucks.
And so no it's been.
No taper inside for you at the moment.
It's the T and that's been one of the harder parts is,
nobody can operate in crisis mode for months on end.
And our city enterprise has done that
for about a year now, you think, I remember,
I remember the beginning of COVID 19,
I had, and this is kind of a crazy story.
Everything kind of fell apart very quickly.
It became clear how horrible the pandemic was going to be.
It became clear that there, it was gonna lead
to a pretty significant economic Downturn.
It was became clear that people were gonna get sick
and tragically people are going to die.
And so we very quickly had to sign an emergency declaration.
And so I had to sign this declaration,
which would give me unilateral authority around issues
to act quickly in the interest of the health
and safety of our community.
Now, at that moment,
when I was signing the emergency declaration with one hand,
in the other hand,
I was FaceTiming with the ultrasound of my future daughter,
and to have the most,
what I thought would be probably the most important thing
in my professional life in one hand,
this emergency declaration is pen.
And on the other hand,
the most important thing in my entire life in the other,
it was surreal and I thought that that was the big test.
And then George Floyd was killed
and this global reckoning around
racial justice and everything else,
the economic downturn, budget shortfalls,
everything else that our city has experienced.
And then you get kind of foisted
into the national spotlight and conversation.
And suddenly there's a white hot light beaming down on you.
And every move that you make
my sense is that no matter what you do,
it's met with all kinds of applause and derision,
but no matter what it is mainly division,
there's gonna be a lot of people who are unhappy with it.
So, yeah, so you're dealing with COVID,
you're dealing with George Floyd, racial,
all the racial issues that have,
monopolize the conversation around Minneapolis.
You've got a baby who's still now, not even a year old,
Some of these things going on, like, I mean,
my head would explode and now you're gonna you're you sure
you want to run for reelection?
You want to do this again?
Well, it's funny.
The topic of reelection was a much longer one,
certainly with my wife than it normally is.
Normally when you decide that,
you want to be a candidate for office,
it's this exciting and momentous occasion,
it's all right what's the big vision.
And what's the coalition we're gonna build
and how are we going to get there?
And it's kind of egotistical in some ways in this time,
it was far more reflective.
It was far more personal in some ways,
because there have been times
when this has not been fun to put it lightly.
It's been tough, it's been hard on my family.
It's been hard on my wife, Frida has no idea.
Frida is my thought she has no idea what's going on
she's thrilled all the time,
but it takes on a new level of difficulty at some time
so but you know what?
It came back to that.
I just feel this very deep seated responsibility,
to get the city through this,
to set an example through which the rest of the country,
the rest of the world even can follow
in terms of what we are willing
and able to do around, around racial justice,
what we're willing and able to do around housing and police
reform and deep structural change there.
And it's hard, it's difficult.
All these topics are controversial
there's no easy answers to any of this stuff.
Yeah it's a platform mean you campaigned
on affordable housing,
you campaigned on police community relations,
on environmental reform, environmental justice,
all of these things.
And then suddenly these do become
so what's the right word,
prominent or in your face in a way
that you could have never imagined, right?
It's like, okay, well, these are the issues
you wanna grapple with, like, here you go.
That's very real and you know,
we spent two years worth of work,
seeing some unprecedented progress.
I mean, we invested more money on a per capita basis
than almost any city in the entire country
and affordable housing.
We got rid of single family exclusive zoning,
which was to say the least very controversial.
And we were the first city in the country to do that.
There was a number of changes that we instituted that yeah,
we're really proud of.
And this last year has been a year of unprecedented
difficulty, unprecedented trauma and in crisis.
And I mean I feel like too many people
have used the word unprecedented in this last year.
So it's almost a little bit cliche,
but that's just the truth.
During these difficult times?
Yeah every day I say stuff like that
and it's both, it feels cliche at times,
but my goodness, it is also true.
What do you see like how,
what is the vision that you hold?
Like how, what is the path forward
from your perspective to get to the other side of this
and create the level of parody that people would like to see
and hopefully reckon with the racial issues
in a manner that sets these things,
aren't gonna be solved obviously anytime soon,
but sets the city in a trajectory like that,
is moving in the right positive direction.
You first always need a level of acknowledgment
that hasn't been there before.
And I think we are actually making
some substantial progress there, you know,
acknowledging that this was not just about
the nine plus minutes of horror that we saw
in the form of the video of George Floyd's killing.
This is about 400 years worth
of very intentional mistreatment.
This is about intentional segregation,
restrictive covenants that run with the land,
Jim Crow all of the other,
horrible and very intentional policies
that have been inflicted at times.
And I think the goal right now beyond acknowledgement
is to make sure that the precision
of our solutions matched the precision of the harm
that was initially inflicted.
And that's always where the "rubber meets the road."
I mean, because that's where people start to push back
because you're talking about all right,
well, here's specifically what we're gonna do.
But you know, these are tough conversations
that are definitely worth having,
and I'm thankful that we are.
Yeah, I mean, the wound is deep
and you can't expedite that healing like that.
The wound has to be exposed to oxygen.
And that feels like the phase that the city is in right now
and the nation, frankly.
I mean, it is weird to be here
and then you flip on CNN or whatever,
and it's like Minneapolis all day long,
like wherever you go.
And that's one of the frustrating parts in a sense,
because you know, the narrative that you always hear
you've heard over the last year is that,
Minneapolis is a city on edge.
Minneapolis is a city on edge I hear that all the time.
And I won't disagree with that,
there is truth there,
but we're also so much beyond that.
Along after that red light of the cable media
is gone long after folks decide
that they're gonna not be focusing
on Minneapolis anymore, for whatever reason.
I mean, we're still gonna be here
in the city that we really love.
And it's an extraordinary place,
and we are this trial,
we are all of these shortcomings
and issues that certainly we need to correct.
And we are also so much more than that at the same time
and it's that nuance that always doesn't get caught,
you know, we're flawed.
And I think the truth is that,
is that flawed nature is certainly not unique
to Minneapolis we are there,
but we are confronting it hopefully very direct.
Yeah, well, truth lives in nuance
and unfortunately, media narrativen
are driven by kind of dualistic perspectives
on these things.
And I was reminded of my own blind spots
with all of this, we went to, I said this on a podcast
the other day, but we went to visit George Floyd square
and after seeing it on television, a thousand times,
I thought I had an idea
of what it would be and what to expect
and it was very different in every material way
than everything I imagined it to be
from the neighborhood to the setting,
to the vibe, to the people,
everything about it was nothing like I had imagined it
and I'd seen it a million times on television.
And the reminder being that,
just when you think you have a grip on something,
you really don't until you experience it,
boots on the ground and as being the leader of this city
and your responsibility to kind of,
shepherd a real narrative about,
the actuality of the events
that have transpired and will transpire,
what do you think?
Like where is the blind spot
that the average person living
wherever doesn't see or doesn't get about the truth
of the experience of living here?
The truth as you mentioned, is always nuanced.
I mean, you mentioned George Floyd square,
George Floyd square is,
and has been both this beautiful place of racial justice
and healing, a critical point
where communities can gather and reflect.
And it's also true that there are times that,
that square in that area have not been safe
to ignore either one of those realities
would be to miss the honest truth.
And it is true that communities around there,
much of them black and brown communities
have suffered in some form due to some upticks and violence.
There's never unanimity of opinion.
There certainly is not now,
but I think in that case,
I mean, it's almost George fleet squares
is emblematic of so many other things
that are happening right now
in that you have these dualities of both
of which are true, you know,
wonderful place to racial justice and reckoning
and instances when it's not safe due
to other outside factors.
Policing, we need deep structural change
to how our police department operates.
We need safety beyond policing
because not every 911 call needs a response
from an officer with a gun and we need police.
There are horrible situations
that we make officers respond to that nobody else wants
to nor can they.
And both of those things are true.
I think the police reform conversation
is the best kind of example,
to explore how truth lives in nuance,
because it's very easy to lapse into this notion
that with respect to Minneapolis,
at least it's either defund the police,
which means a million different things
to a million different people,
but is often characterized as complete abolition
of the police or you're pro military militarization
of the police.
It's an either or situation
and the longer that I'm here
and the more people that I talk to and the deeper,
I kind of educate myself about this issue.
It doesn't seem like there's that much difference
between most of the voices who have a say in policymaking.
It seems that everyone agrees
that the police need deep reform.
Now there's quibbling over
what that might look like
or how that gets implemented.
But aside from an extreme, extreme fringe,
there's nobody who's really saying,
we need to abolish the police department completely.
At least as far as I'm aware,
I don't know You're shaking your head
maybe you can tell me more about that.
And it's really a conversation about
how to best accomplish this goal,
that there seems to be somewhat of a consensus on
is that wrong or what do you think?
For the most part you're right,
following some of those most tumultuous times
after George Floyd was killed,
there were definitely people
that were calling for getting rid of the police.
Sure, sure can we talk about the video?
Sorry about the video.
(laughs)
I'm never gonna live that one down.
I mean, a lot of people probably
who are listening probably saw it,
but correct me if I'm wrong.
It was in the midst of a protest
you were kind of ushered out of your house
and you joined this procession into Downtown
and in front of a large number of people,
a woman, I forget her name sort of publicly asked you
point blank and yes or no fashion,
if you were in favor of defunding the police
and you said that if she meant abolishing the police,
that no, you did not support that.
And that resulted in you being essentially kind
of told to leave and shame on you
and all that kind of stuff.
And there's a video of you kind of walking
through the procession of people
that a lot of people saw and that kind
of became the lightning rod moment
in terms of how people were kind
of contextualizing this debate.
Yeah, it was tough.
And let me tell you, I'm proud of that moment.
I'm proud because I told the truth
when it was especially hard,
it was a large group, as you mentioned
of those protesting that came to my home.
That demanded that I come out
that were asking for answers.
I came out of my home
and I was asked to come up nearby the stage area.
And yeah, I was asked if I would be willing
to commit there on the spot to defunding the police.
And I said very clearly
that I am for deep structural change
of a system that in so many cases has been racist.
I think we need safety beyond policing,
but let me ask you,
what do you mean by that defund the police.
And she said very clearly,
I mean, get rid of the police.
And my answer is no, because that's the truth.
Now the next day I'll note
that there was a strong majority.
In fact, the veto proof majority of the city council
that came back and took the same pledge
that I refused to take and have since almost
every one of them gone back on it.
I'm not gonna say that I'm gonna do something
that I'm not going to follow through on.
And yeah, it was tough.
I mean, it doesn't tickle to get
Game of Thrones style shamed in front of the national media.
But when I talk to black and brown communities in our city,
when I visit the north side,
which I do all the time,
there's a couple of comments that I get
the first is thank you for immediately terminating
those officers and calling for charges.
I mean, there was unanimous praise for you,
getting on that, like immediately,
because that has not been handled
in that type of fashion in other instances, in other cities.
But the second thing that I hear
from our black and brown communities
is thank you for standing with our chief
and not agreeing to defund and abolish the police.
And again...
So what do you make of that?
Well, certainly no community is a monolith,
but if it's based on what I hear,
when I'm out on the street,
if it's based on what the polling clearly says,
it's dead in line our, again,
no community is a monolith.
But what we hear loud and clear
is that they want deep structural change.
Do they want the funding, no.
And there has been some pretty significant reformations
in terms of the police, right?
With the body cams and the ending
of the kind of warrior training
and a couple other things along the way.
The homework I'm impressed,
Yeah, well we've made some major changes.
We added a disciplinary matrix to our body camera policy.
When I came into office was about 55% compliance
with our body camera policy.
Now there's 95% compliance.
So in other words, before 55% of the time
they were turning on their body cameras.
And there's like a consequence.
If like, if that's not true.
They don't turn them on when they should,
there are consequences to it.
The other penalties,
we were the first city in the entire country
to ban warrior style training, both on and off duty.
We overhauled our use of force policy,
we banned No-knock warrants for all,
but exigent circumstances,
we've ensured that deescalation would be added
and embedded in everything that our officer is doing
by requirement and by the reporting structure,
how it's set up.
I mean, I can go on,
there's a litany of other changes that we've made,
but here's the truth,
is that gonna change the culture of our police department
or any police department?
No, it won't, these are policies changes.
So to what extent do they fundamentally alter anything
or are they just band-aids on a system
that needs a deeper kind of redress?
I think they're important changes that will help,
but when you talk about deeper redress,
let's be specific about what we're talking about.
One of the things that I think would make a huge difference
is arbitration reform.
And then I'll get a little specific on this
so we might end up just cutting this part out,
but this is a big deal.
And I think every mayor, every chief is hindered by this,
these laws throughout the whole country.
When chief are down to, or I fire a police officer,
it is mandated that they go through this arbitration system
that sees 50% of those termination
and disciplinary decisions come right back to the city.
So 50% of the time when we fire somebody,
that decision is not upheld
because of this mandatory arbitration
that needs to change.
I think especially with an instances of egregious
use of force or lying on a formal document
that should change.
And there's also a deeper issue as well,
even beyond that, which is,
if you are an organization that is known
for being something,
if you're a podcast that is known for attracting cool,
health oriented people with a good suntan,
and then you go out and recruit
to get additional people to watch your podcast,
who are you gonna attract?
You can do that kind of similarly
if you're a police department that is known for something,
whether that's for being compassionate and service oriented
or that's for being a bunch of racists
and you go out and recruit,
who do you think you're gonna get?
And so it makes it all the more important
that you do this necessary work ahead
of time to change both the reality
and the perception so that you can get
the right individuals in
and then the wrong individuals out.
When you're faced with having
to make an important decision,
which you're doing constantly.
And you've got all these different voices,
and everybody's got a perspective and a point of view,
and these people are donors or their voters,
or they're coming with,
what they're telling you comes with a block of voters
and they can move that one way or the other.
What is your process for getting clarity
so that you can, tell the truth
or vote with your conscious or make the best decision?
Like, is there a method to how you do that,
under extreme duress.
Under times of extreme duress,
especially when you're going through a major crisis.
The truth is that you can't,
send out a poll to determine how every last individual
is feeling.
You have community partners,
you have mentors and individuals within the city
that you look to, that you talk to the get input from.
Usually I try and take multiple sides in,
hear different arguments in play devil's advocate,
wherever I can.
And then you gotta make a decision.
And hopefully most of the time you get that decision right
sometimes you don't.
And that's the nature of being mayor,
I mean, it's different by the way
than when you're in like Congress,
I don't vote, I don't have a vote.
I'm tasked with making decisions
in crisis oriented situations.
And I mean, there's an old LBJ quote that says,
"when the burdens of the presidency get too heavy to carry,
"I just, thank God I'm not a mayor."
We are dealing with all of the other situations
that nobody wants to handle mayors are.
I I've half joked that the,
one of the main jobs of being mayor,
especially right now in Minneapolis,
in other cities in the country,
is to jump on all of the grenades of societal shortcomings.
And you still get blamed by anybody
that gets hit by the truck.
I mean, this is like the era of the mayor,
like when have we been talking about city mayors,
as much as we've been talking about them
over the last 18 months, it's crazy.
And it's a unique and weird job
because on some level it really is about grassroots,
local politics, but mayors do wield a lot of power
to make swift rapid and significant changes.
And that obviously provokes the ire of a lot of people
when it doesn't swing in their direction.
Yeah, they both do and they don't at the same time.
I think the truth is that the things that intrigued you
and excite you, when you get passionate about,
on a very deep level, that's Congress,
that's the federal government in many cases,
that's healthcare, universal health care
and these broad sweeping, rights,
marriage equality, things like that.
There's a debate debated ad nauseum
and move at a very glacial pace.
Exactly and you can take a vote
and maybe there's a chance that
in a year or two, you see the impact from it,
the things that really piss you off,
usually that's what mayors are dealing with
now in these last couple of years,
mayors have been taking on more.
And I think rightfully so,
because there has been all of this gridlock
at state and federal legislatures.
And so mayors have just stepped in and said,
we're gonna just do it.
And we're gonna take the wrath
or the credit well, along with it.
But depending on which city you're in,
in many cases, mayors have all of the responsibility,
but none of the authority and in Minneapolis,
we have this kind of gray system
that is not a strong mayor system.
We do not have the system that Chicago has or St. Paul has.
We have a system that is more decentralized than that.
And so you oftentimes get blamed for things
that aren't deserved.
You also get credit for things that aren't deserved also.
And that the truth is always a little bit more greater
than it's presented.
What do you think,
like people fundamentally misunderstand
the most about what your job entails?
I mean, I think there's often the perception
that you can wave a magic wand
and make something happen immediately.
I think there's the perception
that you have authority over things
that you just don't have authority over.
And there's also all of the other aspects
that people don't see that happen behind the scenes.
There's these heartfelt conversations
with community members,
there are complexities that go well beyond a hashtag
on Twitter or a soundbite
that you'll get in a two minute news conference.
And often times people don't see that
and this is, I think at least in part,
a causal element of something that social media
has caused over times.
And there's certainly a lot of positives associated with it.
There's definitely negatives too.
Yeah, I mean, as somebody who lives in the media,
you're in the media constantly,
I don't know that you've done any podcasts.
Maybe you've done a podcast or two?
I did the daily.
You did. Oh, you did the daily.
But that's still like pretty, that's brief.
Like I wanted to give you the opportunity in kind of
a space where we can breathe,
where it's like safe,
where you can kind of express your perspectives
without fear of it getting chopped up and mis-characterized,
or taken out of context.
So in that therapeutic.
And so thanks that.
(overlapping conversation)
In that spirit, like I'm interested in,
it must be frustrating for you
when you see, you pop up in some news program
and they're taking some clip or you're,
participating in one of those squawk box things
where everyone's shouting and you have three seconds
to express your point of view.
What do you think in your message gets lost in that,
that you would want people to better understand?
I know it's a vague question, but.
There have been instances
when one particular event
or policy has been misconstrued for the most part,
I've actually really appreciated the way
that our media has handled things.
Of course they're issues that I'll always be off about.
That's inevitable.
What I see that is problematic though,
is the polar extremes.
You the very far white supremacis,
the very far and archist left spinning narratives
that just have no basis whatsoever in reality.
And also seem to push to dehumanize people
in a big way I am a human being,
I have skills, I have flaws, I'm a human being.
And every day you get up
and you try to do your very best,
you try to take an honest and compassionate approach.
And sometimes all that gets all that gets lost,
depending on how those that wanna speak up,
whether they like it or not.
Well, just by dent of being mayor,
you become the receivership for everybody's angst
and I, or whatever's bothering them,
or whatever problem that they're having.
Like, you're the target for them.
Well, and you see, I think you see both ends of it.
And I think this is probably the case
for so many probably elected officials
and I guess celebrities at times as well,
you're, neither is good nor are you as bad
as the media or social media makes you out to be,
there was a back in 2019,
I want to say there, Donald Trump came to town.
I know where you going just go ahead.
And Donald Trump came to town.
He, we were forced to basically foot the bill
for all of these major security expenses associated
with his visit to our city.
And I didn't wanna pay for those security expenses
I certainly, we want the taxpayer
to have to foot the bill.
And so we said directly to the campaign,
this was not even publicly at this point.
This was like, we just don't think it's right
for us to do this.
And then immediately,
the Republican party took it up that Donald Trump
started going after us on social media
and we responded it.
All it was, was a stupid tweet.
I didn't do anything heroic,
but you're suddenly made into Zack.
It's really put you in the national spotlight
in a big way, it was the idea was he was coming to town
for a big mega rally.
It's gonna be this huge to do
and you're like, our taxpayers need not pay for this.
Here's the bill it's $530,000.
And as long as you pay it, it's all good.
And that just led him on fire.
He got pissed off his whole
his support is start attacking,
you gotta wear a Bulletproof vest as mayor for a few days
because of that, because you've got all these,
anti-Semitic white supremacist whatever,
agitators that want to come in and scare you now.
But in that moment, there wasn't anything spectacular
about what I did I get tons of credit.
And I don't know that it was necessarily even deserved.
Now similarly there have been instances
where I've been in it,
which has been in the exact opposite,
instances that I'm proud of, but you just get ripped apart.
And so you're, neither is good nor are you as bad
as things seem to be in that particular moment,
whatever it is that's the truth.
Then the skirmish with Trump continued,
you got into this thing in the midst of
when the George Floyd protests were starting to peak,
or he went after you for being weak
and you defended yourself.
And that's where the classic,
when the looting starts the shooting starts tweets
happened that got flagged by Twitter.
And that really set in motion,
his ultimate de platforming,
like that was kind of a monumental tweet storm
that went down.
I mean, that had to been wild for you in that.
It was wild and I actually didn't,
I think I was informed of those tweets
while I was in a press conference at the time,
which was needless to say one of the worst press conferences
and performances that I gave largely
because I was exhausted at that point.
I think we were three or four days in,
and the things that Donald Trump spouts off needless
to say are, I mean, not just irresponsible.
I mean, my goodness sometimes they were evil
and thankfully he doesn't have that platform
at the moment anyway.
What is the a day in the life look like for you
is every day different?
Is there like a walk me through
like how it all works.
Every day is different and it depends on the time.
I mean, when I first took office,
we were on the verge of having the super bowl
just a month after I took office,
we had arguably the largest sporting event
in the entire world, other than maybe the Olympics
in the world cup right here in our city.
And things look like, it was constant briefings,
getting prepared for safety and security measures.
It was welcoming people to town,
welcoming Philadelphia Eagles fans,
as much as I didn't really care for them.
It was meeting celebrities the times
and I mean, that was the bizarre time in and of itself.
There are days where it's just policy all day long.
And there are also days where you're just sprinting
from one event to the next
that are diametric opposites.
I mean, you're going from a funeral of a firefighter
who has died of cancer.
And then you're wiping away tears in your eyes
and heading over to do a raw event,
celebrating Minneapolis and some extraordinary new program
or business that's coming to town.
And that's the weird part
and that's where at times trying
because it feels fake sometimes
you're in this sad state at one event
and you're in the car, maybe sometimes a staff,
sometimes you were alone and you have to, like,
as Brogan says, you gotta fake it.
You got to like intentionally put on this smile
that is...
So that's what Brogan's been doing this whole time
(chuckles) sitting over there.
You gotta force off
it was force it you're right.
Force it is far better than fake it.
I should've gone with that,
but as Brogan says you force it,
and you do have to force it.
And sometimes you start out forcing it
for the first couple of minutes
and then it actually becomes genuine by minute six.
But that's kind of the reality of these days
and I mean I try to get runs in
whether they were really relate
as much as possible because that grounds me
and my staff know when I have not gotten in my run,
my wife certainly is aware.
You have to run every.
You got to run, you gotta run.
I can't imagine how you would like your,
just your ability to manage
that level of stress day in day out
is improved so much from that level of self care.
When you run, do you have to run with a security detail
or can you just go out and run?
Yeah, we had a discussion about that early on.
And that was like definitively rejected by me
I was like, this is, no, you know,
there are times when I want to run with nobody.
There are times when I just want to zone out,
not say not talk and just kind of be
in that moment with my breath.
It's meditation in a way
I'm also a very talkative and extroverted person.
And one of the main things
that I miss about my running career is not the races
certainly not the hard workouts.
It's the comradery it's running with the guys
So I run routinely with Brogan.
I mean, that's an extra version explosion.
Brogan has been giving high fives to every other person
that he sees.
He actually can't get anywhere
cause he has to stop on every street corner
and strike up a conversation.
So you're grooming Brogan to be the mayor
who's gonna follow in your footsteps.
He's already the mayor of deep cave at,
or wherever the hell you're living in suburbia.
I was going for a run with actually
a New York times reporter who was in town,
John Agar I haven't met him
but I know he's, he's here covering everything.
So do know the story you already?
No.
And so I had just largely ditched Brogan
the night before I was like,
hey I can not gonna run the next day with you I now,
because I was gonna get a run with John
and I show up to pick up John,
outside of his hotel.
And we start on the run within a half a block,
he turns to me and he says,
so do you know a guy named Brogan?
(laughs)
Of course, who doesn't know Brogan
but of course unbelievable.
And as it turns out this like,
tall goofball dude and rollerblades
had come up to him maybe seven months prior.
Pink socks and green polka dot hat.
Struck up a conversation.
That's pretty much Brogan,
Brogan the other day we're walking down the street
and he strikes up a conversation with somebody
they've been talking for 10 seconds and he goes,
how do you think our friendships going?
Are we getting onto the right track?
Do you feel good about where this is all headed?
(laughing)
See no right out of the playbook, anyway, yeah, man.
I mean, I can't imagine you being the runner
that you are not making time to run,
but also understanding that there are gonna be days
where that's just impossible.
Some days, some days it is just impossible.
And I mean, ideal world for me
is I run five times a week,
maybe four to seven, eight miles per hour.
That's kind of like the ideal sweet spot for me
I don't need to go more than that anymore,
I don't need to crank any sort of crazy fast pace out,
but just getting out there and breathing in the movement.
I mean, it's heaven in so many of those checks.
Be honest with me,
what's the casual pace these days?
I think it probably varies somewhat
well, first off you go,
the pace that whoever you're running with,
if somebody...
Happy slowing and a half minutes.
If you person you're running with a six and a half,
you turn up juice and you hit it,
I start pretty slow.
I would say eight and a half minutes a mile.
This is if I'm on my own.
And I usually finish the last couple
of miles around pretty hard,
Six minutes sometimes even faster to get.
Yeah just for people that are listening,
who maybe don't have a frame of reference a two 16 marathon
is what's that like five, 12 pigs around that.
Somewhere around that and,
this is without the fancy shoes.
(overlapping conversation)
And I'm just telling people, my PR is 209 because...
Did you follow Desirees 50K world record the other day?
I did, I was dead in watch it at the time,
but I saw that she set the world record
for the 50 K was the first woman under three hours I believe
and then I started slugging beer out of her shoe.
Like, like really consistent 5 47
it's pretty much across the board.
Just keep going 5 47, well, I mean,
she's a metronome that way
and she was tough on him guess
when I was out there running with the Hanson shoes,
she was busted up, she was injured.
I think she had some sort of stress fracture.
She was not any sort of like,
I mean, she was always talented obviously,
but like she was not crushing it at the time.
But she's tough, she grinds.
The harder, the circumstances,
the more she's able to shine,
which is why she liked that moment
at the Boston marathon was so,
It was so incredible I mean,
in my favorite moments with Dez
are not running its partying.
I mean I remember more moments of partying with her
and her husband and Brian Sell
who was out there at the time as well,
who was the blue collar runner.
Do you know Josh Cox then too?
I've met Josh Cox,
I can't say I know him really well though.
Do you still follow running and marathoning
and all that pretty closely?
Yeah I do?
No, it's there's I definitely stay in touch with those
that are still involved in the sport.
I mean it's such a beautiful sport to follow.
What else is part of your routine?
Are you a meditator?
I'm not, I mean I'm not a meditator in traditional form,
but I guess there are probably many forms of Medicaid.
I mean, I'm not on the ground,
with my legs crossed and I don't do that.
I've tried it my mind wanders too much.
I know that those that are more experienced meditators
would probably say that's okay.
I would get frustrated I use breath and mantra,
which always has worked for me.
It's repetition of a phrase to sort of set my mind
and ground myself.
And I mean, my wife just calls it,
talking to myself, but that's what I'm doing.
Yeah, well, I would consider that meditation.
So there you go you can say that you're a meditator.
I am a meditator, I will say the next time someone asks.
Where's this all going for you?
I mean, do you imagine yourself,
being mayor here and like, what's next,
do you think about the future?
What's your vision for your own career and your life?
I think everybody thinks about
what their future is and what it holds.
I also think that my vision for my future
has probably changed dramatically
in the last year and a half.
If you'd ask me two years ago,
I think I would have been pretty enthusiastic
about a longer career in politics.
if you ask me right now,
I feel a deep seated responsibility
and I love being mayor,
not withstanding everything else.
I still do love this job.
Do I love it on a daily basis?
No, You know, I don't,
but at the end of the day there's this feeling
that you can kind of work hand in hand with community,
towards the betterment of people.
And like, I love that.
And so I love mayor, I wanna be mayor,
but do I want to do anything beyond that?
Honestly, I don't know.
If standing here today, I would say absolutely not.
I have no interest in being in Congress
for a number of reasons.
One, I mean with the exception of recently,
traditionally they haven't gotten a lot done,
but also I don't want to be flying back
and forth for selfish reasons.
I don't want to be flying back
and forth between DC and Minnesota.
I got a family, I have a wonderful wife, Sarah,
we have a baby.
I want to be with my family
rather than flying back and forth without them.
The campaign piece, I mean,
typically around now is where
that would kind of kick into high gear.
But I suspect that the pressures of the job
or making that not that kind of goes out the window.
Campaign has not,
is barely happened at all over these last several months
and I expect the next several months to come.
It's just such a lesser priority
than keeping the city safe through this time
and making sure that people are okay.
And so no way 98% of my time is really devoted to that.
Well, I feel like setting aside
the kind of urgency of what this city
is enduring at the moment,
you being the accomplished elite endurance athlete
that you are,
and the kind of robustness of this city
with respect to its parks and its bike ways
and everything that it has to offer
in terms of outside activity and adventure,
puts you in this position to be kind
of like the wellness mayor, like,
because you live this lifestyle
and you're in a city that's so conducive
to these kinds of participation, oriented endeavors,
that that feels like a leadership role that suits you well,
does that resonate for you?
Of course it does.
It's like if everything was calm
and there was nothing going on here,
maybe you could focus on that now
is not the moment for that.
Used to focus on that all the time.
I've got this incredible story
that I got to tell you
about Abdi Bile have you heard of this guy?
Yes.
So Abdi Bile somali man won the world championships
for the 1500 meters.
He was the best miler in the entire world back
in 89, 88, 90 in that timeframe.
And he went to George Mason University,
which was right down the street from where I lived.
And when I was like a ten-year-old,
I used to take the bus over to George Mason University
to try to warm up with some of these guys
that were there at the time.
I mean, Abdi Bile was there,
Julius H Shawn was there a little after that,
but Abdi was like my hero.
And there was this one day where I was running alone,
like 10 years old and I see this tall,
dark lanky figure running towards me
and he gets close I realized, oh my God.
It's like, it's the world champion Abdi Bile
and I thought to myself,
I'll never forgive myself if I don't turn around
and run with them.
So I did, I turned around,
I started running with them
and I was so excited for this moment
that I probably quickened my pace a little bit.
And I was one stepping him and I member
he put his hand on my shoulder and he said to me,
Jacob is not important how fast you go
it is only important that you go with purpose.
And at the time I thought this was like some Somali proverb
or famous saying that he was just repeating.
But now 30 years later, having getting to know him
is just how the guy talks now.
He was the crazy thing.
So, and that moment when I was running with them,
I don't think I saw Abdi Bile in person
for the next 25 years,
fast forward 25 years I'm the mayor of Minneapolis,
this is a couple of years ago.
I get a message on Facebook or text or something like that
says, this is Abdi Bile I'm coming out to Minneapolis
and would love to get a chance to run with you as mayor.
And I was like, oh, you gotta be kidding me.
This is this unbelievable full circle moment.
And he came out,
I don't think he remembered this interaction by the way,
from 25 years prior, I was just some schmuck kid,
but I ran with them along the river.
And as we were going past towards one of the most scenic
areas of our entire city, he says to me,
I think I could live out here.
And maybe I'd like to start a youth running program to help,
some of these youth that might otherwise go down
the wrong route.
And I was like, oh my God, yes, we're gonna set this up
we recruited him, got him out here
and he's now running a whole program for largely Somali,
some not youth right around running.
Pretty cool.
Yeah, that's very cool.
I was speaking to Anthony Taylor earlier
who's very much,
in that world of trying to provide access to outdoor spaces
and outdoor activities to that community.
And it's super inspiring,
like work and there's so much work to be done there,
but perhaps the most kind of gratifying thing
that you could do it's cool.
So do you go out and run with them now?
Every now and again yeah we get in a run.
He's just such a jolly happy person
he's learning to cross country ski now,
which I am also,
I did not get out once this last winter,
but in general I try to get out the door.
I've never done that,
but it feels like a natural shift for anybody.
Who's an endurance runner.
It's not.
It's not?
It wasn't for me.
I know that it's really hard and it just kicks your ass.
Well, I don't, I never got my
it's a rhythm that you got to get into
and it's a whole motion,
especially if you're doing skate ski,
which is what I think is the,
that's the coolest most beautiful motion.
I mean, that's the one where you're going like this.
And I think for me,
I'm so used to the motion of the back kick of running
that the skate ski motion, just, I,
it just has taken me a while to learn,
not to mention I did not grow up skiing.
I didn't grow up ice skating, any of that.
And so this whole concept of you are in a relatively,
still position while the ground is moving under you.
You know what I mean?
You're sliding, that's not something
that I've really been comfortable with it.
There's a fluidity to it,
but your parents were both professional dancers.
So I feel like, yeah, you should be able to figure this out,
Figure It out, who knows?
Maybe, yeah.
What was that like two professional dancers?
I mean, that's a very interesting.
My parents met in New York City,
the dance for the Lubovitch Company in New York City
and then the Netherlands dance theater and Holland.
And they're pretty big time
my father was on the cover of like dancers magazine
and he hurt his back while he was in Belgium
and a chiropractor, fixed them up.
And he was kind of towards
the end of his dance career anyway.
So he decided to become a chiropractor,
moved back to the states
and he continues to treat
some of the dance companies anyway, that come through.
So he's still has that connection,
but my parents were very involved
in the dance world growing up,
the basement was just a big mirror,
where they would use to...
why did they come?
Why DC?
I think they wanted to be in the vicinity
of an urban area, but not necessarily in it.
We grew up in Northern Virginia largely
and I mean, I got access to the Kennedy Center there,
a number of different ballets come through access
to culture and the arts and all the things
that they really valued.
And you know, most of the other,
my other siblings have more of an artistic talents
perhaps than I do. Yeah.
That's wild. Yeah.
They did that and...
Are they still around, they good?
They're doing, they're doing well,
they're doing well, they're still in the Washington DC area.
And what is your, what is your wife do?
My wife Sarah is a, she does governmental relations.
She's a lobbyist for
predominantly Early Childhood Education Organizations.
She helps represent low-income kids at the Capitol
to make sure that they're treated fairly
and justly and have the right.
These organizations have the right resources.
She represents the ACLU,
a number of different organizations.
Well, I love the city.
I'd like to come back and in the summertime.
(laughing)
My blood is thin these days
but the trails and the outdoor spaces here
are really something still.
It's incredible.
I mean, there's nothing like Minneapolis
no, I love it.
I didn't grow up here,
but it is just an extraordinary place.
Maybe the way to kind of round this out and end.
It is just sort of with some thoughts
on what you would like people to better understand
about this city,
because it's so much in the news
and people are forming their own ideas based on,
the snippets that they're seeing.
I mean, like I said, there's always this duality,
it is a truth that we have a long way to go
with respect to racial justice and reckoning.
It is true that we need deep change
to our police department
and that we have these long-term and systemic inequities
between whites and black community.
It's also true that we've got this beautifully diverse city
that people really love each other here deep down.
And I mean, whether it's, I mean, we're known to be
like the healthiest city in the entire country,
depending on which one of those ridiculous surveys
that you read.
We've got the best park system in the entire country,
routinely rated number one.
And it's a beautiful and extraordinary place to live.
And so much of that gets missed,
especially over this last year.
But my goodness its true.
And reckoning was some really important, big issues?
Yeah and my, what I'd like to see coming out,
all of this is, yes we will always be the city
where George Floyd was killed.
We can also be the city where we did something about it.
We can be this hopefully example of justice
and inclusion that others can follow.
So out of this really hard year,
we hope to see a whole lot of progress.
Well, it's good talking to you, man.
It's good talking to you Rich
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Best of luck try and get some sleep.
I do need the runs.
I haven't gotten in one and in a better part of six days
or so I've come back and we can...
When are you leaving?
Tomorrow morning.
But I'll be back if Brogan has anything to say about it.
Cool man, thank you, appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
All right, We did it a different kind of role on
Adam How do you feel?
what I love about roll on it's plug and play.
It is, and we can be free with the format,
We switched it up.
We did.
Do you think people liked it?
Did they not like it?
Leave a comment, let us know what you think.
We'll be back to listen to our questions.
They'll comment, they don't need your permission.
(laughs)
I don't have to give them permission to comment really?
They'll comment and we will read those comments.
I don't know if I'm gonna read them.
You will.
We'll be back in two weeks.
In the meantime, give Adam a follow at Adam Skolnick.
You can follow me at Rich Roll.
If you want your question answered,
leave us a message 4 2 4 2 3 5 4 6 2 6.
Visit the show notes on the episodePage@richroll.com.
We'll have links up to all the articles
and all the stuff that we talked about
to immerse yourself in the experience
that you had today.
Don't forget to hit that subscribe button on YouTube,
on Apple, on Spotify all the places,
we got eclipse channel up on YouTube.
So if you dig short chunks from the show,
or you wanna sample a guest before fully committing,
it's a big commitment to commit to a podcast episode.
We're talking about 2 hours.
Thanks for committing.
So I appreciate the commitment,
but if you're on the fence about that,
you can check the clips by just searching
Rich Roll Podcast clips on YouTube--
And then maybe see a therapist
about your commitment issues
That would be advised.
I support that(laughs).
See professional.
Hey dude, I love you, Adam.
I love you too Rich.
We will talk again soon, my friend.
Appreciate all you guys love you.
See you back here in a couple of days
with another amazing episode until then take us out.
Peace
(both) plants.
(upbeat music)